So Leute, ich hab am Start, ich muss gerade noch was futtern, sonst mach ich das wie das letzte Ball, wo wir gestriemt haben, dass ich das Essen hier stehen hab, erst um 14 Uhr Frühstück, dass sie auch nicht sind und weg.
Soll ich euch mal eine absolut geniale Erfindung zeigen?
Wo ich mir gestern zwei Stück bei Amazon bestellt hab, sowas hab ich schon eine ganze Weile gesucht, aber es gab nur bis in diese Richtung.
Aber jetzt hab ich das Geile gefunden. Passt mal auf, und zwar, was ich gefunden hab, SwitchBot. Und zwar funktioniert das folgendermaßen, aus dem Dumm, so früh schon.
Wenn Sonntag morgens, morgens bin ich gains gemacht.
Genau, guck was ich gefunden hab, und zwar, pass mal auf, seht ihrs? Richtig cool, ist ne Box, die für ein Knopf drückt, guck mal.
Na jetzt labert ein bisschen, noch mal angucken. Hier, beim Lichtschalter zeigt das jetzt.
Mach mal auf, mach mal dran. Mach mal dran. Ja, blablabla. Na jetzt pass mal auf. Zack, das ist cool, oder? Das ist huge. Excellent ist das, excellent.
Link, ganz einfach, einfach bei Amazon. Gibt's sogar in Deutschland. SwitchBot.
Ich finde 25 Euro ist okay. Man kann sagen, für so ne einfache Box mit Schalter ist schon ganz schön teuer, aber es ist...
Introducing the SwitchBot.
Haha, mit Katzen wurde aber nicht gedacht. Ja, aber guck, so ist das gedacht. Das ist eigentlich richtig cool.
Na gut, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben vielleicht. Zack. Du kannst halt normale Schalter damit schalten, wo du nicht irgendwie nen Relay dazwischen basteln willst, oder unter die Dose irgendwas basteln willst,
oder gar nicht kannst, wenn es zum Beispiel an Fernsehen ist, oder so. Das ist richtig, das ist richtig big brain.
Kann ich zum Beispiel verwenden, für den Keller, für die Heizung im Keller, zum ein und ausschalten, für alle möglichen Sachen.
Das ist so ein typischer Ami-Switch, weil du da alles in die Wand schneiden kannst.
Die App braucht man übrigens auch nicht, weil, wenn man hier auf GitHub sucht, findet man jede Menge Projekte, mit denen man den SwitchBot kontrollieren kann, ohne dass man die offizielle App braucht.
Also im Prinzip, das Top, das Ding, ob es das bei Aliexpress gibt. Oh ne, jetzt hab ich auf Chinesisch umgestellt, fuck.
Vielleicht gibt es sowas auch bei Aliexpress, nur bin ich egal.
Hi Noob, Stufe 1, für 2 Monate Big Brain Sub.
Das ist richtig cool, also das gefällt mir.
Jetzt dann 2 Stück bestellt, von den SwitchBots.
Gibt es einen Grund, die offizielle App nicht zu benutzen? Nö, wenn dir das reicht nicht. Das ist soweit ich das gesehen hab, ohne Cloud oder so.
Einfach rein lokal über Bluetooth oder, weiß nicht ob WLAN auch eine Option ist.
Hey hier, Bluetooth.
Nö, gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund, wenn du damit zufrieden bist, die offizielle App nicht zu benutzen.
Aber, bei mir funktioniert es halt mit der offiziellen App nicht.
Weil ich will es ja über meine zentrale Heimautomatisierung steuern und da bringt es mir nichts, wenn ich auf dem Handy in der App einen Knopf drücken muss, dass es schaltet.
Will ich ja zentral steuern können, nicht über die App.
Aber wenn dir das reicht mit der App, gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund, das nicht über die App zu machen.
Aber an sich ist die Idee schon ganz cool, vor allem, die haben halt für Schalter, die du reverse schalten musst, nix ist auch so ein paar Kleber dabei.
Dass quasi, wenn der Schalter eigentlich ausgeht, macht er ihn an.
Erkennt man ja hier, das ist hier so diese Dinger dran gepappt, da kann man sich auch noch ein Set extra kaufen.
Diese Dinger machst du dann hier vorne halt an den Lichtschalter beispielsweise und hier an den Switchboard.
Und wenn der Schalter dann quasi ausgeht, sieht er das raus und macht das an.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee. Es gab sowas vor einer Weile schon mal, so Button oder so hieß das.
Aber das gibt es...
...irgendwas anderes.
Das ist ein Half-Life Logo.
Das gibt es irgendwie nicht mehr und der war auch nicht so schön wie der hier.
Das hier macht einen richtig runde Eindruck.
Er unterstützt standardmäßig ja schon alles, was die normalen Leute so haben wollen.
Da ist jetzt hier Alexa, Google Home, Siri, IFTTT.
Allerdings, nachdem ganz normales Bluetooth ist, habe ich euch ja gerade gezeigt, gibt es auf GitHub jede Menge Projekte, die das auch können.
Einmal musst du ja.
Gucken, was uns YouTube heute empfiehlt.
Chris Stonehenge, zwei Monate.
Der IQ steigt heute unermesslich.
Hi IQ, Morning.
Und dann gibt es irgendwas wichtiges, was wir uns angucken.
Wollen wir gucken, was uns YouTube so empfiehlt.
Ja, Profil wird anders, als ihr denkt.
Ich denke dazu ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht viel.
Außer, dass das Ding halt nicht cool ausgeschaut hat.
Das interessiert mich, was die Games da zum Multiplayer sagen.
Mich ist das so ein gewollt und nicht verkämpfter Mr. Multiplayer von Modern Warfare.
Gucken, was die Games da dazu sagten.
Sogar senden sie Ravageflame, das Game.
Das ist bestimmt nicht so einfach.
Das ist bestimmt auch lustig.
Der schlecht bewertete Experte zum Computer repariert.
Schon den neuen Virtual-Code GTA San Andreas Any% gesehen.
Nee, hab ich nicht. Wie lang geht der?
Using BadLinux.com.
Alter, warum sind die Leute immer so excited, wenn sie vor der Kamera stehen?
Hey Leute, was geht? Ich bin wieder am Start und heute zeige ich euch die geilsten...
Sind immer alle so über- übertrieben gehypt.
So redet doch keiner normal.
Moin und Frage, kann man einen Twitch-Chatbot der Songrequests von Spotify macht, mal in dein Stream machen.
Das wird also aus dem Grund nicht funktionieren.
Außerdem sind Songrequests immer so eine Sache.
Es wird wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil entweder benutzt, um irgendwelche Trollmusik abzuspielen.
Oder es wird wahrscheinlich Musik sein, die mir nicht gefällt.
Deswegen glaube ich, ist das keine so gut.
Da knabbern wir irgendwie sowas, wobei ich nicht weiß, inwieweit es bei Spotify überhaupt geht.
Das GTA San Andreas... Ach guck mal, das GTA Plus.
Geht da bloß 15 Minuten, kann man sich was angucken.
Ich dachte, dass ich von GTA San Andreas überhaupt keinen blassen Schimmer habe.
Welche Monitorgröße hältst du für toll?
Kommt ein bisschen auf den Schreibtisch an.
Aber ich habe letztens einen richtig geilen Monitor gesehen und zwar...
Ich glaube Heise hat da einen Test zu.
Den würde ich kaufen, aber den fand ich nur übelst heiss.
Samsung?
Irgendwie so ein Curved Monitor war das.
Das sah ultra nice aus.
Was war das denn für einer?
Der war übelst nice, ich finde den jetzt irgendwie.
Aber den würde ich mir eh nicht kaufen.
Das war so ein 1.29.
Das war so ein riesen fettes Monitording.
Rock Life Hustler 3D Prime.
Also ich habe die ganze Zeit schon einen 21,5 Zoll.
Weil ich sitze ziemlich nah davor.
144 Hz, 21,5 oder 22.
Ansonsten hängt es halt auch ein bisschen davon ab, was man so für Vorlieben hat.
Also rein zum Spielen würde ich halt irgendetwas nehmen, wo du beim normalen Sitzen vorm Schreibtisch den kompletten Monitor im Blickfeld drin hast.
Das Video war es da...
Oder war es bei Golem? Ich weiß es nicht.
Das sah total affig aus, weil das Ding so riesig war, dass derjenige, der davor gesessen hat...
Die haben CS gespielt, der musste quasi...
Da hast du richtig gesehen, der hat permanent seinen Kopf gedreht.
Das willst du natürlich beim Spielen nicht haben, Kopf drehen ist kacke.
Augen bewegen muss reichen.
Also ich würde mir hier auf dem Schreibtisch maximal 23 Zoll stellen.
Vielleicht wenn ich den zweiten Monitor mal abschaffen sollte, vielleicht ein 27 Zoll oder sowas.
Aber sonderlich sinnvoll scheint mir das Ganze nicht zu sein.
Zumal ich mir jetzt eh 240 Hz Monitor kaufen würde.
Da ist ja die Auswahl jetzt nicht so riesengroß.
Da gibt es ja nur irgendwie 20-30 Stück oder so.
Da gab es doch letztens irgendwie eine coole Seite, die wir hatten.
Wo alle 240 Hz Monitor verglichen.
Jetzt hätte ich mal Bock machen sollen.
Zumindest würde ich mir jetzt eh einen 200 Hz Monitor kaufen.
Es könnte aber PC Games Hardware geben.
Ich würde mir jetzt eh einen 240 Hz Monitor kaufen, rein wenn es ums Gaming geht.
Weil bisher habe ich mir jahrelang keine neue Monitor gekauft.
Weil ich mir gesagt habe, ich habe einen Monitor in der Größe, die ich haben will, mit 144 Hz.
Was anderes Besseres gab es eh nicht wirklich, was jetzt einen riesen Sprung gemacht hätte.
Das E, Anthem, geh weg.
Wo kommt man hier auf die aktuellen Tests?
Ja, Gaming Monitor Test, genau.
Wo sind die 240 Hz?
Da haben wir letztens schon mal geguckt.
Die Dinger sind halt relativ teuer.
Kostet halt schon ein bisschen was.
240 Hz Monitor, aber wenn ich mir jetzt einen Monitor kaufen würde.
Irgendeinen von denen, die gut abgeschnitten haben und 200 Hz haben.
Weil das halt einfach nice ist.
Vor allem wenn man einen Rechner hat, der auch 240 Hz packt.
Also nicht 240 Hz, sondern mehr FPS.
Dementsprechend ist es auch immer lustig.
Ich kann zu den Grafik Sachen in den meisten Games gar nichts sagen.
Ich stelle das alles immer auf Low.
Also was gucken wir jetzt?
Das Video wollte ich schon ewig mal gucken für euch.
History of Rainbow Road World Records
Samsung
Das ist ein 32 Zoll.
Der wäre mir zu groß.
Schreibt nicht 32, aber das Geschmackssache.
Was ist das für ein Panel?
Sehe ich das jetzt?
VAR Panel?
32 im Namen ist schon stark nach 32 Zoll aus.
Das haben die ja alle mehr oder weniger.
Das ist aber auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, das macht natürlich einen Unterschied was Farben angeht.
Aber ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin jetzt da jemand, der ist nicht so ultra anspruchsvoll was das geht.
Wenn ich normal vor dem Monitor sitze, das Ding mal kalibriert habe.
Und das okay aussieht, dann reicht mir das.
Es braucht kein super teures Panel.
Hab ich zur Not im Fernsehen.
Macht doch eigentlich einen ganz guten Eindruck das Ding.
Findest du die MSI Optics Max Serie sagt mir überhaupt nichts.
Klingt nach RGB.
Ah Curved Monitor.
Curved ist auch nicht so mein Fall, weil man da auch den Kopf eher dreht.
Ich habe ja einen Curved auf der Arbeit.
Finde ich persönlich nicht so toll.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit einen riesen Monitor, weiß nicht wie groß der ist, 32 Zoll oder so.
Curved 4K.
Kann er nicht 4K sein, müsste er wahrscheinlich 3x4K oder so.
Ganz breiten haben wir auf der Arbeit.
Aber auch von Samsung.
Der sieht fast ein bisschen aus wie der hier.
Und ich bin da kein großer Fan von Curved.
Wie gesagt ich verwende das Ding jeden Tag auf der Arbeit.
Und Curved Monitor ist nicht...
Ich meine man kann damit arbeiten, das ist schlimm oder so.
Aber wenn ich es mir aussuchen dürfte würde ich einen nehmen der nicht gecurved ist.
Was ist deine Auflösungsreferenz 1080p?
Also zumindest bei dem was ich gerade habe.
Mein Monitor ist ja nicht ultra wide hier gerade.
Auch nicht irgendwie sonst wie Special 1080p.
Weil für mich ist FPS wichtiger als Auflösung.
Ich will viel FPS.
Deswegen stelle ich die Games ja auch immer auf Low Quali.
Wenn ich nicht meine 200 plus FPS kriege kann ich nicht richtig spielen.
Ich habe einen guten 4K Monitor leider nicht.
Extreme Nerd, 2 Monate, Dankeschön.
Ayayaya.
Ja, no second plan.
Wenn ich mir einen neuen Monitor kaufe wird es auch ein relativ kleiner 200 FPS Monitor werden.
Ich habe jetzt eine Waffe für Easy Nukes.
Okay, wir müssen uns ja immer ein Fortschnitt Video angucken.
Da können wir damit heute mal warten.
Easy Nukes.
In Modern Warfare ist Astronomal mit Nukes eh nichts.
Außer in Ground War.
Weil alle in der Ecke sitzen.
Aber wir gucken uns mal die Easy Nukes an.
What the?
PS4, er spielt noch nicht immer Master Race.
Da kann ja nichts passieren.
VA, was ist das TN Panel?
Was ist das TN Panel eigentlich?
Ich habe es übrigens gerade verwechselt.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit gesagt VA.
Die meisten günstigen Sachen sind auch TN Panel.
Aber rein zum Spielen ist es nicht.
Yo, chill.
I didn't have to do them like that.
Nukes auf Konsole ist wie eine Dreierkille zu die Offensive.
Na ja, ganz so schlimm ist es nicht.
John Promillo.
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen.
Da falle ich nicht drauf rein.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Hört ihr die Musik im Hintergrund?
Excellent Musik.
Ah, yes.
Exquisite Musik.
Oh my gosh, I can't die.
I'm on a 20.
Yo, come on.
Yo, are you kidding me?
Yo, what is going on guys?
Fortunate here and today we are back on Modern Warfare.
Got another nuke for you guys.
Today we are going to be using the PKM.
Basically this gun is like the PKP from Modern Warfare 3.
Habe ich doch nicht einmal eingestellt im Klasseneditor.
I'm letting you guys know now, you need to use this gun.
It is insanely overpowered.
If you land the first shot, I want to say 90% of the time you are going to win the gunfight regardless.
Because this gun takes like two...
Hashtag sagt CodCommunis sind doch nur Konsolen.
CodCommunis sind doch nur Konsolen.
Ja, aber Konsole sackt.
Ganz einfach.
Außerdem, Call of Duty Community sind überall, egal wo, sind durch die Bank bei Galen immer ganz dicht.
Übrigens, ey, ich hab noch nie so viel Hate, wo sich die Leute einig waren, gegen den Call of Duty.
Ihr seht noch nie, wie bei Modern Warfare.
Ihr müsst mal die Twitter-Accounts der Pros verfolgen.
Ihr müsst mal Reddit gucken in den Call of Duty Subreddits.
Dieses Game wird gehasst des Todes.
Nicht so dieses übliche, jedes neue Call of Duty ist doof nach den ersten zwei Wochen.
Sondern so richtig gehasst.
Ich mein, teilweise auch zurecht.
Da hat man nicht vergessen, wenn man sich Maps anguckt, wo du in Sichtweite der Gegner spawnst,
beziehungsweise an der richtigen Stelle immer in den Spawner gehörst.
Du guckst ja immer diese London-Map an.
Vergessen, wie sie heißt.
Also, ist der Witz.
Am Anfang fanden es noch alle geil.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das war schon am ersten Tag.
Das war schon in der Beta.
In der Beta haben sich alle gefreut.
Als man dann ein bisschen gespielt hat.
Also in dieser 2 war es das 2-Beta.
Das fanden eigentlich alle ganz cool.
Aber danach ist, also nachdem die normale Multiplayer-Beta gestartet ist,
war schon das Echo eigentlich relativ eindeutig.
Warum spielen es denn Leute?
Ja, ist halt so.
Also erstens, oftmals die Leute, die am meisten meckern,
sind halt auch die treuesten Fans von Inglis 3.
Aber es gibt heute Leute, die spielen keine Ahnung.
RuneScape oder so.
Ja, du wirst immer Leute finden, die irgendwie was spielen und die ganze Zeit...
Guck dir, guck dir.
Bestes Beispiel dafür ist doch eigentlich World of Warcraft.
So die richtigen Langzeit-World of Warcraft-Spieler,
die schon seit Klassik dabei sind,
da ist ein ganz hoher Prozentsatz von denen die noch dabei sind.
Die haben die ganze Zeit immer über das aktuelle World of Warcraft gemeckert.
Haben trotzdem weiter gespielt.
Aber beim aktuellen Modern Warfare ist es ein bisschen anders.
Es ist nicht so dieses normale Gemäckere,
was man bei den anderen Call of Duty Teilen hatte.
Sondern es ist relativ zielgerichtetes,
sogar relativ sachliches Umgemecker.
Also die Call of Duty normalerweise ist doch eigentlich eher sinnloses Umgeflame.
Fuck you, Shotgun OP, you suck, get good, best game ever,
scheiß Noobs, scheiß PC-Spieler, scheiß Konsolenspieler.
Die sind eigentlich sehr relativ random, die meisten Call of Duty Flames.
Und die letzten Jahren auch.
Aber wenn man sich das dieses Jahr anguckt,
ist es sehr zielgerichtet, relativ sachlich.
Also man sieht, dass die Leute sich zum größten Teil einig sind,
was so eigentlich vorkommt.
Das heißt, da muss schon was dran sein,
sonst würde das nicht so in eine Richtung gehen.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Aber ich hab's ja in einem Video gesagt,
dass... oder Failor muss zur Kreismeisterschaft.
Ja, viel Erfolg.
In was denn?
Bestimmt, ja.
Big Brain Schach oder sowas.
Äh, wo war ich jetzt gerade dabei?
Ja, da muss schon irgendwie was dran sein,
wenn das so in eine Richtung geht, wie da gemeckert wird.
Aber ich hab's ja in einem Video gesagt,
es ist auf jeden Fall Absicht, dass das Game so ist.
Es ist nicht so, als hätten sie das gesagt.
Aber guckt euch das an auf Twitter.
Irgendwelche Pros, die keinen Bock mehr haben zu spielen.
Vor allem jetzt, wenn sie ihre komische Call of Duty-Liga starten wollen.
Es ist schon relativ bitter, wie das gerade um das Game aussieht.
Ich verstehe nicht, die Leute bei Skill-Base-Matchmaking rumheulen,
weil nichts mehr mit Noob-Splashen ist.
Das ganze Game ist halt darauf ausgelegt,
dass du mit Killstreaks und solchen Geschichten
Up- und Down-Runden hast.
Sprich Runden, wo du halt auch mal den Juggernaut raushauen kannst.
Und das Problem ist, das ist jetzt halt nicht mehr so dadurch.
Das ganze Spiel ist, also ein Call of Duty Public
ist einfach nicht auf Skill-Base-Matchmaking ausgelegt.
Allein schon, dass es 20er-Killstreaks gibt.
Du kriegst einen 20er-Killstreak,
kriegst du in einem Game mit Skill-Base-Matchmaking,
kriegst du nur hin, alle Schaltjahre mal.
Und dann auch nur, wenn du ultra-defensiv spielst.
Niemand kriegt einen Juggernaut,
wenn er gegen gleich gute Gegner will,
und über die Meer brennt.
Geht einfach nicht.
Vielleicht einmal der gesamte Lebensdauer des Spiels oder so.
Deswegen bin ich der Meinung,
dass Public-Matchmaking in Call of Duty
muss ohne Skill-Base-Matchmaking sein,
aber halt Up- und Down.
Es kann durchaus sein,
dass du gegen fünf gute Gegner gematcht wirst,
und dein eigenes Team mega sackt,
und du voll auf die Fresse kriegst.
In der nächsten Runde ist es umgedreht.
Bei den Gegnern werden halt fünf totale Bobs reingematcht.
Und dann gehst du ab wie Sau.
Die ganzen Noobs sehen das anders.
Naja, es ist ja trotzdem, wenn es random ist,
es ist ja immer noch, sagen wir mal, relativ ausgeglichen.
Ich bin der Meinung, die Noobs haben da auch nichts von.
Weil so wie es jetzt ist,
spielt jeder um sein Leben jede Runde.
Und wenn es random ist,
hast du immer mal wieder Runden dabei,
wo du halt auch als Noob ganz gut abgehst.
Was so jetzt halt nicht ist,
so hat jeder ungefähr seine 1 bis 1,5er KD.
Und das muss meiner Meinung nach Public Call of Duty auch so sein.
Sonst macht es keinen Bock,
und sonst ist es auch komplett sinnlos,
wie das Spiel aufgebaut ist, was Killstreaks und sowas angeht.
Call of Duty ist auf Killstreaks,
im Endeffekt auf Chains und auf Kills machen ausgelegt.
Das ist Public einfach kein Objective Game,
zumal du für Objectives auch nichts kriegst als Belohnung in diesem Teil.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
wenn das Spiel so gebaut ist,
aber es dann nicht zulässt,
ist es schon irgendwie ein bisschen in Konflikt.
Passt ja auch nicht.
Es passt ja auch nicht, dass du sagst,
wir machen ein Game,
du wirst Public bashen mit Killstreaks,
und dann ist es fast nicht möglich,
und das ist genau das, was du in dem Spiel siehst,
dass jeder extrem krass defensiv spielt.
Auch wenn er mehr Bock hätte, rumzurennen,
aber den Leuten ist einfach KD und Killstreaks erreichen das Wichtigste in Call of Duty.
Das heißt es ist so ein bisschen in Konflikt,
dass das Game auf der einen Seite so gebaut ist,
dass das immer noch in Vordergrund gestellt wird,
weil es gibt ja auch keine Belohnung für Objectives,
nach dem Motto KD ist gut,
Killstreaks sind gut,
aber auf der anderen Seite,
das Game hier quasi Steine in den Weg legt,
dass du das nicht nutzen kannst.
Das Problem ist doch, dass selbst die größten Noobs rumschwitzen,
ja Noobs sind immer noch Noobs,
es ist egal, ob Noobs rumschwitzen,
natürlich schwitzen Noobs rum, egal.
Jeder schwitzt im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten.
Leute die sacken,
auch wenn sie sich anstrengen.
Warum lädst du deine Twitch-Teams,
weil die viel zu lang und uninteressant sind,
also für YouTube,
und die Leute viel zu wenig aufmerksam,
keinen Spanner auf YouTube.
Wozu? Keiner, kriegste Abo's.
Oh Chat, stimmt,
wir haben kein Chat eingeplant.
Ja, Chat, immer noch.
Ja ich weiß, es gibt einen Perk,
dass KDs in Punkten sind,
aber du musst Ghost verwenden,
das ist glaube ich im gleichen Slot wie Ghost, oder?
Ohne Ghost kannst du sie eh nicht spielen.
Geh, wir gucken uns erstmal die Nuke von ihm an.
Natürlich Crown War, aber sonst, ne?
Gun only Nuke in normalen Spielbody
gegen gute Gegner ist ja nicht drinne.
Also nicht von ihm, von niemand.
Deswegen gibt es kaum Nuke-Gameplays,
und wenn es Nuke-Gameplays gibt,
ist es entweder Crown War oder
die ultra-reverse-boosteten Boblobbies.
Das ist ja auch das Problem dabei.
Nachdem die Leute ja quasi
im Kopf das so drinne haben,
dass KD gut und Killstreaks gut
und das Game ja auch irgendwie drauf ausgelegt ist,
die logischste Konsequenz, die jetzt passiert ist,
für gute Gameplays wird erstmal
reverse-boostet ohne Ende.
Oder es wird Crown War sich aufs Dach gelegt
oder ins Haus gelegt.
Let's get right into the video!
Hände ihm aber auch heftig rein.
Thank you.
Reloading real quick.
We should have some company coming our way.
Come on, the other guy runnin'.
I guess I'm gonna call my VTOL.
I mean, I'm calling her on the cliff
or something.
Yo, I still can't get over the fact
how quick this gun kills people, bro.
The second, this, literally
the second year first shot hits them,
they're like dead.
They can't even react.
Dead.
Yo, I actually
cannot believe how good this gun is.
In a sense, it kinda reminds me of the
RPG damage-wise
from Modern Warfare 2.
It has the iron sight, obviously,
of the PKP from Modern Warfare 3, right?
In Modern Warfare 3, the gun's called
the PKP. In this game, it's the PKM.
They got a gunship, dude.
Like, what is going on?
And then let me get this nuke real quick, too.
Dude, there's no way
he should die that quick, that's crazy!
People stompin'.
I don't know where that guy even came from.
Alright, we're down some more ammo.
I wanna run back to our D.
Gibt es auf der Konsole
wenigstens diese komischen, diese komischen Balken
als Anzeige, wenn es keine
Ping-Anzeige gibt?
D, but I don't wanna get
mopped up, I'm by the fire.
Hast du haltest house-migrations
auf der Konsole?
...
Aber es gibt noch nicht mal Balken.
Das ist ja fein.
You're dead.
Also, weißt du, was ich für eine Verbindung zu überhaben hab?
Holy crap, dude!
No way this is going on right now!
Oh my gosh, I can't die.
Dude, this thing is so
stupid and ridiculous!
You look at people and they're dead!
Thank you, Claymore, for the assistance.
It's kinda screwed up,
because they have A and D. Spawns
got all jacked up. Heads up, there's a guy over here.
Dead. The only thing that could benefit me a lot
right now would be a nice UAV.
Okay, dude, just not this.
Oh, that was close. Claymore kill nice.
Okay.
Leute, das einzig Gute, was ich finde,
für rumlaufen in Modern Warfare,
ist tatsächlich die Schütze.
Whoever got that UAV, god bless them.
The only thing this gun needs is some reasonable
quickdraw speed, and it would be
godly.
It is godly, but dude,
if it had the speed like that,
that kid is dead.
That kid is deleted, oh my gosh.
There's no point in using any other gun.
Another one dead.
I'm gonna reload real quick before I end up screwing myself.
Der ist nur im Haus da, ja.
So muss man das Spiel her spielen.
Das ist genau das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe,
wo manche hier gesagt haben, das wäre nicht so.
Du musst, dass du bist da jetzt
und normalerweise schlussst.
Ich muss nur meine letzten Töne
aus dem Ausflug holen.
Er stirbt auf dem Flugzeug.
Ich habe ihn, wow, das war verrückt.
Das war mein 29. Töne, ich brauche einen weiteren Töne.
Ich habe eigentlich die Scheiße aus dem
Helikopter geflogen.
Okay, wo kann ich einen weiteren Töne bekommen?
Einen weiteren Töne, dude.
Kann mir keiner erzählen, dass er in dem Game
konstant, wir reden nicht mal von einer Runde
irgendwie alle 20 oder 50,
konstant
über die Map rennt
und gute Scores hinkriegt.
Das gibt's nicht.
Es sei denn, das sind halt Gameplays,
die explizit darauf erspielt wurden
mit vorher 20 Runden
und diverse Boosten.
Yo, I got it, let's go, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, dude.
Let's go.
Dude, last hit.
I'm lucky this thing shoots a freaking laser beam.
Oh my god, dude, I can't believe I got...
Yo, this is my second game
using this gun, dude.
Oh my god.
Level 100 nuke for god.
Well done.
Wow, okay.
You're dead.
Come on, run in the door, I know you're over there.
Ich finde,
das ist ein gutes Comment.
Dominic, nee, nicht Dominic.
Die Dominic vermutlich wurde.
Das Game fühlt sich nicht gut an,
finde ich.
Das einzige, was sich in dem Game gut anfühlt,
ist, wie sich die Waffen anfühlen.
Das finde ich
das einzig Gute,
warum man immer sagt, das Game fühlt sich gut an.
Die Waffen fühlen sich gut an.
Die Waffen unterschießen mit den Waffen,
das fühlt sich gut an.
Das Treffen, das Feedback und
Gegner killen, das fühlt sich gut an.
Also der reine, reine
Core-Shooting-Mechanics,
die fühlen sich gut an. Der Rest drum herum
fühlt sich irgendwie
unzusammen,
passt nicht so richtig zusammen.
Auf der einen Seite möchte man eben
KD und Killstreaks haben
und auf der anderen Seite
ausgeglichenes
1,5er, 1er KD
Play auf merkwürdigen Maps.
Das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Das ist ein Spiel,
was zwei entgegengesetzte Sachen
parallel machen möchte.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, wenn sie ihre
Call of Duty Liga machen.
Ob die überhaupt genug Bros finden, die das Spiel
spielen wollen.
Oder sie müssen so viel Call ausgeben,
dass die Leute quasi Schmerzensgeld
bekommen, das zu spielen.
Guckt euch mal, viele große Orgas
haben keine Call of Duty Liga,
beziehungsweise die Bluttyrern
alle laufen.
Angeblich soll das Game 5 Jahre
Entwicklungsteil haben. Kann schon sein.
Technisch ist das Spiel auch echt okay.
Die technische Seite
der Witz ist,
Modern Warfare kommt mir vor, als hätten das zwei
unterschiedliche Teams gemacht.
Leute
auf der technischen Seite,
sowohl von der Grafik her
also Leute, die
für die Optik zuständig waren
und für die Technik,
die haben einen guten Job gemacht.
Die Leute, die für das eigentliche Design
des Games zuständig waren, waren
Schizophren.
In dem zwei Sachen gleichzeitig gewollt
werden, die nicht zusammenpassen.
Und was sie mit den Webdesignern gemacht haben,
waren sie nicht genau.
Trader Joe HD.
Wie sieht es inzwischen auf der PC Version
mit Hackern aus?
Will ich ausschließen, dass es da welche gibt?
Gibt in jedem Call of Duty Hacker auf dem PC.
An dem Spot habe ich auch viel rumgehackt.
Das ist ein Hockenstock.
Was man jetzt hier auch schön sieht,
wie kacke die Maps eigentlich sind,
wie uninspiriert. Ich meine,
ich mache in irgendeinem
Terrain Editor
quasi schneide ich
eine Map aus,
und dann stelle ich ein paar Häuser
und ein paar Kisten hin und fertig ist die Map.
An Battle.net gibt es
eigentlich keine Probleme mehr.
Das wäre natürlich gut.
Das wäre also besser.
Weil die letzten Teile waren ja wirklich nach
keine Ahnung, zwei Minuten.
Was ich besonders witzig finde,
ist, dass sie ja quasi
im Vorfeld damit geworben haben,
dass sie auch Leute aus Modern Warfare
mit am Start haben, die da
Maps gemacht haben. Keine Ahnung,
inwieweit da was dran ist,
aber entweder haben sie die nicht
machen lassen,
was sie wollten, oder
die waren damals, keine Ahnung, Praktikanten
bei Modern Warfare 3
und wollten mal unbedingt
ganz viele Containermaps bauen.
Ich meine, ganz ehrlich, diese Maps,
man sieht es von hier oben
gar nicht. Mir geht es gar nicht
mal so sehr um den Aufbau.
Das ist so unglaublich
dubig
gemacht.
Ich habe früher in Half-Life 1
ein bisschen Maps
gebastelt. Es ist schon ewig her,
es haben viele Leute Maps gebastelt, es gibt von mir keine Map, die irgendwie so nicht
bekannt ist oder so, aber ich habe ein bisschen
Maps gebastelt zu Half-Life 1.
Und
das, womit man angefangen hat
Maps zu bauen,
ist tatsächlich so,
wie viele dieser Maps hier aussehen.
Also sprich, man ist hingegangen,
man hat
eine Ebene unter,
einen Eben Untergrund gemacht, ein paar Felswände
außendrum herum gesetzt.
Wenn man richtig cool war,
hat man diese V-Variante von Felswände
damals in Half-Life 1 gemacht, also sprich
ein V-Felswand, das V dann quasi umgedreht
und dran gesetzt, dass es so ein bisschen
gewölbt aussieht.
Du hast quasi einen Eben-Undergrund
gemacht, du hast Felswände außendrum.
Und dann hast du die Maps gefüllt
mit Containern,
Kisten und
den immer wieder
gleichen Häuser-Prefabs.
Und genau
so, ohne Scheiß, genau
so sieht halt diese Map aus.
So als hat die der übelste
Map-Editor-Noob erstellt.
Die Map hätte ich auch erstellen
können und ich bin nun wirklich kein großartiger
Map-Designer.
Also genau so
sieht das aus, das sieht aus wie eine meiner ersten
Half-Life Maps, natürlich nicht so groß,
das ging damals nicht, aber
das verstehe ich auch.
Soll ich mal?
Silos, Kisten,
Prefab Häuser,
Obische Treppen,
Container.
Das ist uninspirierend.
Aber ich glaube, die Waffe muss ich echt mal spielen,
das sieht ganz cool aus.
Ein Phänomen
Ein Phänomen hat dieses Game, was ich mir
noch nicht so genau erklären kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Du merkst
die ganzen Sachen, die dir auf den Sack gehen
und du merkst auch, wie unfähig das an manchen
Stellen erstellt wurde, aber
irgendwie hat dieses Game
einen gewissen, ich weiß nicht
was es ist, aber
du hast oftmals das Gefühl, wenn du
fertig gespielt hast und mal 10 Minuten gewartet
hast, willst du noch mal eine Runde spielen.
Und ich glaube,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, woran das liegt.
Ich glaube, das liegt einfach daran, dass es im Kern
also dieses reine
zielen und auf Gegner schießen.
Dass das ziemlich gut gemacht ist.
Und dann spielst du
wieder eine Runde und merkst eigentlich, wie schlecht
alles andere drum herum gemacht ist, dass du
sagst, okay, jetzt nervt mich das drum herum
mehr als der eigentlich
gute Kern.
Dann machst du wieder aus.
Wenn du das Game ausgemacht hast, denkst du dir,
ja eigentlich ist das Game im Kern noch
nice und willst wieder eine Runde
spielen, bis du dann wieder merkst,
dass das drum herum dich wieder mehr abfuckt
als der eigentliche Game Kern. Und so geht das dann
immer im Kreis. Das Game hat ein ganz
merkwürdiges, ganz merkwürdiges
Verhalten, so irgendwie. Du willst,
obwohl es dir auf den Keks gehen aus, weil dann willst du
danach in einer halben Stunde willst du noch eine Runde spielen.
Aber lang kannst du es
nicht machen.
Okay, der war auch huge blind.
Hast du von dem Big Overhaul
MW Modern Warfare gehört?
Der angeblich... Nö, hab ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht. Aber Phantom bestimmt.
Der ergänzt mit sowas ja aus.
Nee, nee, hab ich nicht gehört.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt. Ich mein, das Game,
wie gesagt, ich hab's ja am Anfang gesagt,
ich hab noch nie so
zielgerichtetes negatives Feedback von
allen Seiten gesehen, was in die gleiche Richtung geht
wie bei
Modern Warfare.
Es wurde bei Call of Duty immer schon
geflamed, aber noch nie,
wir können uns das gleich mal angucken,
aber noch nie
so zielgerichtet
und auch fundiert, wie das die
meisten Leute in Modern Warfare machen.
Also das ist selten,
da ist definitiv was dran,
wenn das von so vielen unterschiedlichen
Leuten in die gleiche Richtung geht.
Guck gleich mal bei Charlie Intel,
was hat er eigentlich?
Ich mein, die müssen ja auch was machen.
Das Spiel ist ja auf Dauer nichts.
Ich mein, wenn
die eigenen Pros schon
reihenweise retiren von diesem Game,
das sagt doch alles.
Gibt es denn in dieser Zeit auch wieder Spawn-Traps?
Noch viel besser!
Du musst auf der London-Maps gar keine Spawn trappen,
du kannst einfach so in den Spawn gucken.
Da musst du expert getrappt werden,
und dann kannst du einfach einfach
in den Spawn schauen.
Ja, Fanto, da hast du recht.
Vor allem, wie sie sich schon rumdrücken,
um überhaupt mal Infos rauszugeben.
Es gibt so viele Leute,
die quasi schon gecheckt haben,
dass Reverse-Boosten funktioniert,
dass je nachdem, wie du performst,
du einkopierst wirst und sowas,
und sie lassen sich einfach nicht
mal da irgendwie eine normale Aussage zu machen.
Sie haben bloß mal irgendwie in einem Interview gesagt,
dass sie
irgendwie versuchen wollen,
dass das Noobs gut klarkommen
oder sowas, aber das kannst du jetzt auch
auf sich erwarten interpretieren.
Dem großen Overhaul gibt es dann wahrscheinlich auch
Surprise-Mechanics
oder Lootboxen oder sowas.
Tja, echt?
Das kann passieren.
Okay, da werde ich jetzt stoppen.
Doch.
Ich dachte, das stimmte nur die Pille.
Hier ist ja auch so.
Und Leute, die zwar 35 sind,
aber nicht wirklich 35.
Guck mich mal an, Leute.
Ich bin 35, ja?
Mache ich irgendwie den Eindruck, als bin ich 35,
wenn ich hier rum sitze und sage
irgendwie Five-Fat-Wine-Excellent-Pock?
Das wirkt voll erwachsen 35, oder?
Ja.
Alter, schreibe ich in der Nacht, ja?
Okay, gucken wir mal bei Charlie Inter,
was die da noch zu Neues schreiben.
Oder habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt,
Battlefield V habe ich so keinen Bock drauf gehabt,
wenn sie das gar nicht mehr verfolgt haben.
Was ist hier die richtige?
Over...
Ja.
Overhaul.
List of Potential DLC...
Rust?
Die größte Kackmap überhaupt?
Ich weiß, die ganzen Kreisel-Scope-Sniper
stehen auf Rust, ja?
Aber warum soll man Rust remaken?
Es gibt so viel bessere Maps.
Das ist so, wie laufend Nuketown remaked wird.
Nuketown ist auch die übelste Kackmap,
aber irgendwie 40.000 Mal remaked.
War das jetzt Absicht, dass die Darstellung
im YouTube-Player mit jedem deiner Huster
kleiner resized ist?
Was?
Der Gebannte, ja.
Ja, es hat jede Map seine Fans,
Nuketown hat viele Fans, deswegen wird es
auch so oft remaked, aber Nuketown ist
trotzdem eine Kackmap.
Ok, also was haben wir hier?
Rumor!
Also...
Terminal!
Aber gut. Crash, auch gut.
Fake, auch gut.
Broadcast, auch gut.
Scrap, ja.
Na ja.
Fand ich jetzt auch in MW2 nicht so geil.
Aber auf jeden Fall
alles mal besser als das, was schon dabei ist.
Rust.
Was? Sex vs. Sex
auf Rust?
Wie soll man auf Rust
Sex vs. Sex spielen?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Alle im Container
sitzen oder was?
Para.
Ok, was auch immer.
Boneyard, Caged,
Hook.
Neue Ground Warmaps, drei Gunfight Maps.
Doch nicht Confirm, denn die Confirm
ja auch nichts. Danke generell.
Das ist bestimmt
so eine Notlösung, so nach dem Motto
Scheiße, unsere Maps sind echt kacke.
Lass uns einfach mal welche aus
alten Teilen importieren.
Wahrscheinlich wird es auch so sein, die neuen Maps
werden zack und die alten werden ganz ok sein.
Strike hätte man auch nehmen.
Overcron.
Ah, es gab schon viele.
Darfst du Link posten, klar.
Minimap Returning
to Normal.
Das ist so eine Sache ehrlich gesagt.
Ich finde das vom Ansatz her gar nicht
Gucken wir uns gleich mal
gar nicht so blöd, wie sie es jetzt
gemacht haben, dass du halt die Minimap
mit URV hast und oben diese komische
Sonalleiste
ist gar nicht so doof.
Allerdings verstehe ich nicht so genau,
warum man das wieder so halbherzig macht.
Entweder sagt man, hey es gibt
keine Punkte,
dann gibt es halt auch keine Punkte
oder man kann es mit der Minimap machen.
Dieses halbe halbe ist irgendwie
merkwürdig.
Na ja, Gamer,
das ist ja nicht so, dass es
unsinniges rumgehate wäre an dem Game.
Da ist ja viel berechtigte Kritik
dabei.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass die es wirklich
versucht haben, der Community in irgendeiner Art
und Weise Recht zu machen. Die haben versucht
ihre
Ziele, die sie vorgegeben bekommen
haben, umzusetzen, wie auch immer die ausgesehen
sein sollen. Wie auch immer die ausgesehen haben.
Und es gibt ja auch Sachen in dem Game,
wie beispielsweise eben die
Vorgeschichten, wie
Aimen, Schießen,
Zielen,
Gegner treffen und so.
Das sagt ja auch beispielsweise jeder, das ist ganz gut gelungen,
aber das drumherum nicht. Und es ist diesmal
ja komplett anders,
als in anderen Call of Duty vorher,
wo in alle Richtungen rumgeflamt wurde.
Jeder hatte irgendwas, was
er kacke fand
und hat halt wild rumgeflamt.
Von wegen Shotguns
kacke, Maps kacke, zuviel
Camper, Perks Scheiße.
Das ging in alle Richtungen, aber diesmal
geht die Kritik doch wirklich ziemlich
zielgerichtet
von fast allen, von überall,
wo man so liest, überall, wo man so hört,
recht zielgerichtet in eine Richtung. Und wenn
deine eigenen Pros
reinweise keinen Bock haben, das Spiel zu
aufhören wollen
und es fraglich ist, ob
du genug Leute für deine Liga zusammenkriegst,
dann sollte man sich da schon mal
Gedanken machen, ob da nicht
irgendwas stimmt, äh nicht stimmt.
Und mehr Zeit geben,
macht dir die Spawns beispielsweise auf
der London Map auch nicht besser.
Ich mein, ganz ehrlich,
wenn eine Map baut,
wo du in den Spawn gucken kannst,
reinweise,
die keinerlei
Struktur und Flow hat,
da bringt es auch nichts,
wenn ich noch mal ein halbes Jahr warte, die wird
dadurch auch nicht besser.
Die spiel ich einfach, das ist krass.
Das Schlimme ist, ich kann mir noch nicht mal
die Namen der Maps wirklich merken.
Wie heißt die London Maps eigentlich noch mal?
Ja, Pritch, Pritch ist auch eklig, ja.
Das Einzige, was ich mir merken kann,
ist Gunrunner, weil ich die schon noch aus der
Beta kannte und gut finde.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann mir die Maps nicht
merken.
Ich seh das immer nur am Ladebildschirm.
Okay.
Hier gibt es ein paar neue Bildchen.
Gunfight, Cage, Cargohook.
Hey, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie die
Chernobyl Map aus God 4.
Mit dem Riesenrad und so.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wundert mich natürlich auch nicht,
wenn man einfach alte Sets irgendwie
recycelt oder so.
Shoot House.
Ich weiß nicht,
was das ist.
Shoot House.
Okay, das ist eine Firing Range
in klein.
6 vs 6, 10 vs...
Stadium, ah, okay.
Zeig mal, zeig mal.
Gulag, das könnte
MW2 abklatscht sein.
Hospital, vielleicht, vielleicht
ist es die,
vielleicht ist es von der Krankenhaus Map
aus dem Singleplayer abgeguckt.
Bringen schon Pros ab für die Liga.
Naja, offiziell, keine Ahnung, aber wenn du mal
liest auf Twitter, wenn du dabei
Pros guckst, viele haben keinen Bock.
Endlich kommt es darauf an, was bezahlt wird.
Online sagt man Amber.
Oasis.
Oasis erinnert mich an
die beste, eine der besten
Bad Company Maps.
Port, Prison.
Rivine?
Wie spricht man das aus?
Rivine? Keine Ahnung, kann ich hier aufsprechen.
Ship, oh nee.
Moment, Shipment.
Die
dümmste Map aller Zeiten gibt es jetzt
in Normal, Day und Night.
Das hat uns natürlich
noch gefehlt, das Shipment.
Ein Viereck mit Zaun rum und drei Containern.
Den brauch ich natürlich Tag und Nacht.
Ganz wichtig.
Alter, was ist denn los?
Vielleicht ist Shipment auch nicht das klassische
Shipment, sondern neues Shipment.
Slums?
Das ist eine MW3 Map.
Das ist die, die in Afrika spielt.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Diese Brücke.
Warte mal,
war das das mit der Brücke?
Nee, nee, das war das, wo man so einen
Weg außenrum herum hatte.
Slums? Slums gab es
glaube ich auch in MW3.
Dann ist aber was anderes, ich glaube nicht, dass...
Wie hieß denn die andere Map
in MW3?
Mission. Mission, ja.
Das kann sein.
Ja.
Die meinte ich.
Wie ihr das wisst,
finde ich schon geil.
Ich sag irgendwas
und der Chat so ja Mission und dann ist es auch
noch Mission, ja.
Auch guck mal, wir haben Bilder davon.
Farida.
Bisschen aus wie...
Ich war gerade ein bisschen wie
Favela. Sieht ein bisschen aus
wie diese MW3 Map.
Bisschen wie Zetown, oder? Vor einer Farbgebung hier.
Ok.
Erstmal wahrscheinlich schön am Fenster
headglitchen.
Rasta.
Das ist die Map, die hat echt niemand gebraucht.
Sie mussten aber einfach
irgendeine Map nehmen, die beliebt ist.
Takedown.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie diese
Black Ops 3 Map.
Ich glaub Black Ops 3 Map.
Wo man diese Agentin
oder was das da war verfolgt.
Könnt ihr euch da noch dran erinnern? Die sah am Ende
auch so aus. Aber die werden wahrscheinlich keine
Trial Maps nehmen.
Borderline.
Was ist denn mit denen ihren Dachfenstern los?
Oder sind das Solar Panels?
Und die Häuser texturierten
sind ja mal wahnsinnig.
Aber gut, das ist ein Ladebildschirm.
Ground War.
Ground War werden wahrscheinlich auch
weiterhin einfach
kässt. Wisst ihr was das Witzige ist, wenn ich mir
diese Map von oben so angucke?
Es war ohne Scheiß.
Es sieht alles außerhalb der Map
interessanter aus als die eigentliche
Map. Oder?
Guckt euch das doch mal an. Das hier sieht viel
interessanter aus, das Gebiet zum Spielen außen
wie die eigentliche Map.
Die Map innen sieht man wieder aus nach
Häuser, Container, sonst
was. Und das hier neben sieht man
richtig nach einer Map aus.
Du hast hier Felder, du hast
irgendwelche kleinen Häuser, Felder. Du hast hier
ein Industriegebiet, hier hast du
irgendwelche riesen Türme, Silos, sonst
was. Häuser, wo du dich verstecken kannst.
Eine große Straße. Und hier
in der Mitte hast du
Büsche, Container.
Guncores.
Ok, das sind jetzt wahrscheinlich
2 vs 2.
Ok, das sieht schlecht aus.
Das sieht echt schlecht aus. Also generell das sieht auch schlecht aus.
Das ist wieder sowas.
Diese Ideen zu einem
wie nennt man das?
Trainingskurs und
Shooting Range, Firing Range
Geschichte. Diese Ideen sind das erste
worauf man kommt, wenn man Maps baut und
anfängt mit Maps zu bauen. Das erste
was man macht ist irgendwie so ein
Schießstand.
Jetzt geht jetzt Flipp Money aus
Leute. Also das da oben finde ich tatsächlich
cool was man hier gesehen hat. Trust braucht
kein Mensch. Aber das Game
braucht halt auch echt dringend
neue ordentliche Maps.
Die Sache ist nur die,
dass meistens
die Maps, die mit einem
Game erscheinen,
auch die Maps sind mit dem
Spieler das Game verbinden bzw.
auch die Aushängeschilder
der Games.
DLC Maps waren das selten.
Mal gucken wie die sich jetzt spielen.
Weil ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen,
dass sich die neuen Maps einfach komplett
anders spielen würden.
Anders spielen werden wie die alten.
Und wenn sie das tun, dann
bestätigt das eigentlich eher
dass sich
Infinity Ward Activation und
alle anderen irgendwie überhaupt nicht so richtig
einig sind, weil die Maps
sind ja nicht ohne Grund so. Die Maps sind so
weil es eben die Vision von
Infinity Ward war, dass
das Spiel sich so spielen soll wie es spielt.
Oder sie sind unfähig. Aber das
würde ich Ihnen noch nicht mal unterstellen.
Und wenn jetzt
Maps kommen die sich komplett anders spielen
heißt das eigentlich eher
dass da komplett Uneinigkeit
herrscht.
Diesmal ist alles kostenlos.
Das stimmt, das ist tatsächlich ein großer Vorteil.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Zumal es bei den alten DLCs ja auch
problematisch war,
dass du die Spielerbase
ziemlich weit unterteilt hast.
Wenn du 4 DLCs
rausgebracht hast, dann hattest du das Problem
jemand hatte das Hauptgame und DLC 3
und jemand hatte DLC 1 und 4
und keiner konnte mit dem anderen irgendwie gematcht werden.
Das war voll für'n Arsch. Das alte
System.
Deswegen lief es ja darauf raus, dass bei
den alten CoDs die Leute nach
einer gewissen Zeit einfach alle DLCs
deinstalliert haben.
Ja, ich denke auch, dass das Game
vom reinen Kern her, also weil wie gesagt
so der reine Kern war, der ganze Kern kam
außen vor, also das reine Handling
der Waffen, wie sich das anfühlt damit zu schießen.
Die Waffen an sich anfühlen.
Auch teilweise die Animationen der Waffen und wie die gemacht sind.
Also wirklich der
Kern, der
innere Kern von diesem Game, der macht Spaß.
Das ist glaube ich auch der Grund, warum viele
Leute, nachdem sie dann eine Weile gespielt haben,
sagen wir mal 2 Stunden gespielt haben, sagen wir, Alter ich muss aus,
man ich kann den Kack nicht maus. Und danach
nach 20 Minuten denken, ey noch eine Runde,
könnte man doch spielen.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Was schreiben sie denn dazu eigentlich?
Was wieder dafür sprechen würde, dass sie sich
irgendwie uneinig sind,
was sie denn jetzt machen sollen?
Heute ist der 3. Oktober.
Nee, nicht der 3. Oktober, heute ist der 3. November.
Nicht Oktober, November.
Das heißt, ich muss noch glaube
16 Tage arbeiten
dieses Jahr, dann habe ich frei
für einen Monat.
Das mit der Minimap waren Fail Expansions
Dafür macht man doch unter anderem eine Beta.
Die haben sich da schon was bei gedacht.
Ich finde es auch vom Ansatz her
gar nicht so unlogisch,
dass man sagt, okay, man macht die Minimap
halt nur für ULV,
also
Punkte nur anzeigen für ULV,
aber dass man dann gleichermaßen oben diese komische,
wie heißt das eigentlich offiziell?
Ich sage immer, diese Echo-Leiste, die man oben hat.
Diese Kompass-Leiste,
dass man da so was drauf sieht,
ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen
wenig zusammenhängend.
Als hätte man
zwei Sachen parallel eingebaut und da nicht gewusst,
wie man sie ordentlich zusammenfügt.
Minimap wird zurück.
Du bist seit einem Monat Abonnent,
das kann ich dir sagen.
Aber bei der Gelegenheit ist es vielleicht gar nicht mal
schlecht zu erwähnen, wenn ihr nämlich
einen Amazon Prime-Account habt, könnt ihr das Ganze
kostenlos mit eurem Twitch-Account verbinden
und einen Streamer eurer
Wahl unterstützen,
ohne dass es euch was kostet. Alle Vorteile für euch,
alle Vorteile für den Streamer und
Amazon bezahlt das Ganze.
Big Brain.
Blablabla, Big Overhaul.
Na gut, so wirklich viel steht jetzt
ja nicht, oder?
Wer ist das überhaupt?
Ich meine, ich kann auch viel leaken,
ohne, dass ich davon
was weiß. Ja, ich kann viel sagen,
wenn der Tag lang ist.
Sub auf Bezos Nacken.
Ja, quasi.
Unsub.
Zauberer, man kann auf Twitch nicht unsubben.
Einmal gesubbt,
immer gesubbt.
Zumindest für einen Monat.
Du hast noch was vergessen,
Herr Krachten, das geht eigentlich noch weiter.
Also wenn schon Copypasta,
dann bitte schön richtig.
Nicht einfach nur halbe Copypasta, Copypasta,
das ist wirklich Noobstyle.
Schmitty2802
hat den Sub gewechselt.
Oh, das war natürlich ein absolut high IQ Move.
Ein Leaker zu Modern Warfare,
der immer recht hat. Okay.
Vielleicht verfolgt das nicht so.
Okay, da ist was dran.
An Sub'n geht,
man muss den Streamer nur dazu bringen,
auf Mixer zu gehen.
Ja, Mixer, ich warte noch auf das Mixer-Angebot.
Also für die, die jetzt auf Mixer gegangen sind,
hat sich das finanziell definitiv gelohnt.
Ob sich das Community technisch so lohnt,
da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
das war bei Shroud und bei Ninja und so,
das ist der Deal für die Rente
beziehungsweise für das
lebenslange Rundum-Sorglos-Paket gewesen.
Das kann man auch keine Mühbel nehmen.
Ja klar, King-Wall.
Wie gesagt, das würde ich auch keine
wirklich Mühbel nehmen,
wenn die auf Mixer gehen
bei so einem fetten Angebot.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde das auch machen.
Ich bin zwar nicht scharf drauf,
auf eine andere Plattform zu gehen,
sei es jetzt YouTube, Mixer, sonst was.
Zumal mein Streamer viel zu klein ist.
Nur mal rein theoretisch,
ich hätte zwei Nullen hinten dran, mehr an den Zuschauern.
Ich würde das auch machen, wenn einer ankommt,
sagt Max, du kriegst 15 Millionen,
dann wäre ich blöd, wenn ich das nicht machen würde.
Das ist der Deal für die Rente,
sag ich doch immer.
Wenn jetzt einer zu mir kommt
und sagt, Max,
ihr wisst, ich hänge wirklich an meinem YouTube-Channel.
Ich hätte schon ewig lange aufhören können,
wenn ich keinen Bock mehr hatte.
Ich hänge an meinem YouTube-Channel, das ist auch krass.
Das größte, was ich jemals
insgesamt gemacht habe.
Aber wenn jetzt einer zu mir kommen würde
und sagt, Max, ich gebe dir zwei Millionen für deinen YouTube-Channel,
würde ich auch sagen, hier, kriegste, haste,
nehme.
Da hätte ich keine Probleme damit.
Ich würde es mir auch für zwei Millionen,
für zwei Millionen würde ich das auch schon machen.
Aber
ich denke nicht, dass das passieren wird.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
du tauschst ja im Endeffekt
schon was Wichtiges,
für das du dir dein Leben lang keine Gedanken mehr machen musst
und es auch nicht gefällt.
So, das wollte ich mir jetzt mal angucken,
was die GameStar zu den Multiplayer sagt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
weil die GameStar Reviews
sind teilweise, also,
ich bin, ich muss mal sagen vorher,
ich bin der Meinung, von den ganzen
Gaming-Magazinen und Sachen,
die wir haben in Deutschland, finde ich,
ist die GameStar noch die scheiteste.
Ja.
Aber gerade
bei solchen Multiplayer-Tests
habe ich manchmal so den Eindruck,
die GameStar hat sich nicht so
ganz mit dem Game beschäftigt.
Allerdings flamet die GameStar auch
nie rum. Also, die machen das
immer relativ neutral.
Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen,
sie machen es mittlerweile besser.
Sie bringen solche Multiplayer-Tests auch immer später raus
und nicht gleich zu Release.
Ähm, gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, was die GameStar zu Modern Warfare
zu sagen hat.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare gibt sich
alle Mühe, 2019 der provokanteste,
aber auch imposanteste Shooter-Release
des Jahres zu sein.
Eine drastische Singleplayer-Kampagne,
ein umfangreicher Multiplayer,
der zurück zu den Stärken der Serie will,
sowie einen Spec Ops Koop-Modus,
der euch...
PS4-Exklusiv.
Kappa HD.
Obwohl ja nicht alles PS4-
exklusiv ist.
Nur dieser komische Survival-Motor.
Schauen wir uns mal an, wie gut das fertige Spiel
letztlich geworden ist.
Kurze Disclaimer am Anfang.
Wundert euch nicht, dass im Video
Konsolen und PC-Material abwechseln.
Das Testvideo wurde sowohl vom GamePro-Kollegen
Tobi Veltin, als auch von mir
und meinem GameStar-Kollegen Philipp Elsner
geschrieben und aufgenommen.
Gespielt wurden logischerweise alle Versionen.
Genug vorgeplänkel, los geht's.
Anders als bei Call of Duty Black Ops 4
war Warfare wieder eine richtige Solo-Kampagne.
Juhu!
Und ganz in alter Call of Duty-Tradition
wird darin ein fiktives, gut-böses Szenario
gezeichnet, das aber bewusst in einigen
Punkten an aktuelle reale Geschehnisse
angelehnt ist.
Als die Terror-Organisation Alcatala
gefährliche chemische Waffen entwendet
und mit einem Anschlag am Piccadilly-Circus
in London für Chaos sorgt,
beginnt für die westlichen Mächte
ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit.
In den Uniformen von CIA-Kämpfer
Alex und SAS-Agent
Kyle Garrick büßt ihr nicht mit die
Waffen und den Alcatala-Boss
sondern geradet dabei auch in die
Wirren im Nahoststaat Ursikstan,
in dem der brutale, abtrünnige
Russen-General Barkov mit seinen
Einheiten die örtliche Bevölkerung unterdrückt.
Unterstützung bekommen die beiden
von Farah Karim, Kommandantin
der Ursikischen
Liberationsfront,
die ihr in zwei Rückblenden
auch selbst spielt,
sowie Captain Price.
Der gute alte John Price ist über weite
Strecken die einzige wirkliche Verbindung
zu den ersten drei Teilen der Reihe.
Der hat so Pauspacken!
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie den gecaptured haben.
Ich muss jedes Mal lachen, wenn ich den sehe.
Karim und Price als Begleitpersonen
wirken deutlich charismatischer als
die Hauptfiguren Alex und Garrick,
auch weil wir später im Spiel mehr
ihre Hintergründe erfahren.
Die beiden Spec-Op-Soldaten bleiben dagegen
bis auf wenige Ausnahmen sehr blass.
Die Geschichte selbst ist abseits
der typischen Schwarz-Weiß-Zeichnung auf einem
soliden Niveau, auch wenn Call of Duty-Veteranen
wirkliche Überraschungen vermissen werden.
Es gibt klar erkennbare Höhepunkte,
den obligatorischen Verrat und ein
ordentliches Finale.
Die Spielzeit der Kampagne ist dagegen keine
Überraschung und fällt äußerst
überschaubar aus. Die insgesamt 14
Missionen haben erfahrene Spieler in knapp
3 Stunden durch.
Das neue Call of Duty will provozieren.
Das ist die Mission, die wir zuletzt
gespielt haben.
Ich müsste eigentlich mal die Kampagne fertig spielen.
Angriffe gegen Kinder,
Folter von Zivilisten,
Waterboarding von Gefangenen.
Alle beteiligten Fraktionen begehen permanent
irgendwelche Kriegsverbrechen.
Wer als Entwickler solch sensible Themen
ins Rampenlicht drückt, muss ihnen auch
irgendwo gerecht werden. Und dem Ansatz
gelingt Call of Duty Modern Warfare sogar
ab und an, die Schrecken dieses modernen
Krieges nachvollziehbar zu illustrieren.
Im Gefecht tragen unsere
oder die feindlichen Leute oft keine Uniform.
Wer versehentlich Zivilisten oder Kollegen trifft,
kassiert direkt das Game Over.
Gerade während eines Bombenanschlags
in London entsteht so eine enorme Panik
und Anspannung. Doch dieses Momentum
verfliegt, sobald uns dämmert,
wie mechanisch die Entwickler immer wieder
die gleichen Provokationen inszenieren.
Jedes Waterboarding, jede
Hinrichtung, jede Kriegstat ist
ein Fingerzeig ein. Guckt mal, wie
heftig dieser Krieg ist. Wir müssen
keine unangenehmen Entscheidungen treffen.
Es gibt keine bitteren Konsequenzen.
Und, anders als bei guten Kriegs-
oder Anti-Kriegsgesche- Vor allem, ist das auch
übel schlecht, die Skripte. Wir haben ja
hier hinten in der Ecke nochmal gestanden,
weil wir uns angucken wollten im Singleplayer.
Weil wir so viel gespielt haben.
Was hier passiert? Wir haben uns hier in die Ecke
gestalten. Es passiert nichts.
Hiernach ist das Skript vorbei.
Oder quasi diese Szene vorbei. Und der Typ
läuft einfach unendlich lang im Kreis.
Und es passiert nichts.
Also man hätte sich ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben können,
dass sie dann wenigstens in die Häuser reinlaufen oder so.
Geschichten wird dieses ganze Geschehen auch nicht
eingeordnet oder in irgendeiner Form aufgearbeitet.
Es wird bloß gezeigt.
Modern Warfare schöpft das Potential der eigenen
Geschichte nicht aus. Der Mumm für die
Storytelling-Meisterklasse für eine spannende
Aussage fehlt. Das Potential
wäre vorhanden, eine spannende
Anti-Kriegsgeschichte zu erzählen und die Grenzen
zwischen Schwarz und Weiß wirklich zu
verwischen. Stattdessen bleiben die Russen
im Schnitt die Bösen, die Amerikaner die Guten
und die gezeigten Kriegsverbrechen in erster
Linie Marketing-Provokation.
Hier waren Spec Ops The Line oder selbst
Metal Gear Solid 3 mit dem Zeichen von Grauzonen
vor Jahren schon weiter.
Spielmechanisch setzt Modern Warfare
in der Kampagne auf das klassische Call of Duty
Prinzip. Ist also größtenteils
die bekannte und immer noch sehr lineare
Schießbude, in der ihr euch dieses Mal
durch das ABC der Special Forces
Szenarien ballert.
Wir kämpfen uns unter anderem durch Waffenfabriken
oder einen Flughafen. Die Amerikanische
Botschaft in Ursikstan, die Innenstadt
von Sankt Petersburg oder infiltrieren
bei Nacht Standorte der Terrorzelle.
Gerade letztgenannte Einsätze sind
unheimlich atmosphärisch inszeniert.
Das stimmt, das haben sie echt gut gemacht.
Abwechslung gibt es da reichlich. Wir markieren unter anderem
vor allem, dass wir da so Rainbow Six-style-mäßig
die Türen anschießen konnten und so. War ganz cool.
Aber halt auch ultra linear und
halt eigentlich kein
richtiges Level.
Die Medizine für Luftangriffe oder
steuern die Drohnen direkt selbst mit
angeklebten Bomben in feindliche
Kampfhelikopter. Und natürlich darf auch eine
Snipermission nicht fehlen, bei der wir
vieles mal sogar Wind und Wind. Die war schlecht,
die Snipermission.
Also, im Vergleich zu anderen Zahlen, die war
echt schlecht. Vor allem das Ende
der Mission soll ja voll der Schocker sein
mit dem, egal.
Kein Spoiler, ja.
Aber das Problem ist, dass die KI sich so
unglaublich dumm angestellt hat, dass der
überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat, weil du die Gegner übelst weggesprayt hast und die Gegner haben nie eine Gefahr dargestellt
und das Ende der Mission soll halt quasi suggerieren, so nach dem Motto du hattest keine andere Wahl, dabei waren die Gegner einfach nur dumm, du musstest einfach nur an der Treppe
campen und konntest da 50.000 Russen wegballern.
Distanz mit einberechnen müssen. Mehr als andere Teile nimmt Modern Warfare an vielen Stellen aber auch bewusst die Luft raus und
reduziert das Tempo, um uns ein bisschen Zeit zum Durchschnaufen zu geben und den einzelnen Kämpfen mehr Gewicht zu verleihen.
Bei unserem ersten Treffen mit Fahrer in Ursikstan müssen wir uns beispielsweise als Arbeiter ausgeben und Steine schleppen, um nicht aufzufallen.
An anderer Stelle lotsen wir die Assistentin eines Botschafters in einer besetzten Botschaft der Überwachungskameras zwischen feindlichen Patrouillen hindurch.
Auffällig und angenehm ist, dass in Modern Warfare, anders als in vielen anderen Serienteilen, nicht ganze Armeen von Gegnern den Bildschirm überrennen.
Insgesamt wirkt das Spiel etwas geerdeter. Ja, es gibt immer noch Szenen mit vielen Gegnerwellen, aber seltener.
Dass sich die Kämpfe in diesem Call of Duty besonders intensiv anfühlen, liegt aber nicht an der geringen Zahl oder gar einer verbesserten KI, die ist
insgesamt weitgehend durchschnittlich, sondern an der Tatsache, dass wir selbst auf dem zweiten, der insgesamt fünf
Schwierigkeitsgrade, gerade mal ein paar Treffer einstecken dürfen, bevor wir das zeitliche segnen.
Dieser Umstand zwingt uns regelmäßig hinter Deckungen und sorgt beim Spielen für einen angenehmen Druck.
Besonders die neue Möglichkeit, sich an Kanten und Ecken aufzustützen und vorsichtig um die Ecke zu lugen, ist eine gelungene Ergänzung.
Ein bisschen was zu kritisieren gibt es aber trotzdem.
Dadurch, dass die Gegner ein bisschen tricksen müssen, um uns gefährlich zu werden, gibt es nervige Trial and Error-Passagen.
Gerade auf hohen Schwierigkeitsgraden muss man einige Passagen quasi auswendig lernen, weil die Gegner unmenschlich schnell schießen können.
Immerhin setzt das Spiel aber regelmäßig faire Check-Punkte.
Unterm Strich bietet die Modern Warfare Kampagne eine unterhaltsame und stellenweise auch bedrückende Erfahrung, die allerdings nicht ganz die Klasse
vergangener Serienteile erreicht.
Jetzt kommen wir zum Multiplayer. Der erste große Pluspunkt in den PvP-Gefechten sind die Waffen.
Noch nie hat sich das Schießen in einem Call of Duty derart wuchtig und rund angefühlt.
Das liegt zum einen daran, dass das Sounddesign zur absoluten Spitzenklasse gehört und sich nicht mal mehr hinter einem Battlefield, dem Meister der Waffengeräusche,
verstecken muss.
Das stimmt, das ist ja das, was ich heute auch gemeint habe. So der Kern des Spiels, so dieses reine
Aim-Schießen-Gegner-Kill und so, das ist nicht schlecht.
Kugeln zischen und pfeifen an unserem Kopf vorbei, der Rückstoß ist förmlich spürbar und Hülsen prasseln klingend auf den Boden.
Zudem merkt man sofort, wie viel Arbeit in die Animationen der Waffen geflossen ist.
Egal, ob wir unsere M4 nachladen oder einen Treffer mit dem Raketenwerfer landen, alles hier fühlt sich flüssig an und vermittelt eine stimmige
Gefechtsatmosphäre.
Diese Liebe zum Detail setzt sich auch bei den Bewegungen fort. Das Movement im Spiel fällt ein bisschen
schwerfälliger aus als in früheren Serienteilen,
dadurch schweben und hassen die Spiele allerdings weniger als noch in WW2 oder Black Ops 4 durch die Maps.
Aber was die Waffen zum endgültigen Star der Show macht, ist der Gunsmith.
In diesem Menü basteln wir an unseren Knarren herum, bis zu 70 Aufsätze stehen uns dafür pro Waffe zur Verfügung.
Vom Schalldämpfer, Übergriffe und Granatwerfer bis zu Visieren bringt jeder Aufsatz nicht nur vor, sondern auch handfeste
Nachteile mit sich. Rüsten wir vom regulären Drassen. Leider, leider
sind die meisten Aufsätze halt komplett sinnlos, weil du willst keinen ADS.
Genau, ich habe irgendwas im Hals.
Du willst kein ADS, Minus haben. Du willst eigentlich kaum das, was die Dinge an Minus bringen, haben, deswegen
machst du viele Aufsätze einfach gar nicht drauf.
Schussmagazin auf eine Trommel mit 100 Schuss auf, leidet zum Beispiel unsere Geschwindigkeit beim Zielen und Bewegen.
Movement Speed und Aim Down Side. Es hat so viele Aufsätze.
Auf eine Trommel mit 100 Schuss auf, leidet zum Beispiel.
So viele Aufsätze oder generell Attachments haben Aim Down Side Speed, Minus,
und Minus Movement Speed, und das will man eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Was mich mal interessieren würde, ob es schon irgendwo Tests gibt, wie viel Minus das wirklich ist.
Weil, was wir ja aus der Vergangenheit wissen, egal ob Call of Duty oder Battlefield, ist, dass diese Anzeigen hier in-game eigentlich nie gestimmt haben.
Gab es auf Reddit ja, müssen wir mal gucken.
Also diese Anzeigen hier in-game eigentlich immer komplett für den Arsch waren.
Deswegen müsste man sich mal gucken, und ich würde nicht wundern, dass wenn hier irgendwo steht, Minus Aim Down Side Speed, dass es das im Prinzip gar nicht macht.
...spiel unsere Geschwindigkeit beim Zielen und Bewegen.
Aus dem Attachment-Warn macht Modern Warfare so eine Balancing-Tugend.
Wir sollen uns genau überlegen, was wir an unserer Waffe anbringen wollen, bevor wir sie in den Kampf mitnehmen.
Denn wer einfach wild drauf losschrauben kann am Ende womöglich für seine Zwecke ein schlechteres Gesamtpaket als vorher.
So bringt der Gunsmith ein taktisches Element in den konstanten Fluss aus Freischaltungen, mit dem uns Modern Warfare bei Laune halten möchte.
Aber tolle Waffen sind auch in einem Shooter nicht die ganze Miete.
Beim Kern-Gameplay geht Modern Warfare zurück zu den Wurzeln und wirft viele der Call of Duty-Konventionen der letzten Jahre über Bord.
Statt das Loadout nach dem Pick-Ten-System zusammenzustellen, wählen wir einfach stets unsere Waffe samt fünf Attachments, drei Perks, zwei Gadgets und ein Field-Upgrade fertig.
Die Specialist-Klassen aus Black Ops 4 mit ihren Heldenfähigkeiten sind ebenfalls passé.
Es gibt keine Exosuits, kein Wallrunning, keine Körperpanzerung und kein Sci-Fi-Gedöns.
Sobald ihr Level 29 erreicht, wird das ganze System ein bisschen komplexer, aber es bleibt die ganze Zeit nachvollziehbar.
Modern Warfare reduziert das Spiel auf das Wesentliche und lässt vorrangig den Skill mit der Waffe entscheiden.
Gepaart mit der kurzen Time-to-Kill spielt sich Call of Duty im Jahr 2019 puristischer als seine Vorgänger, aber auch erbarmungsloser.
Sind wir dem Gegner im Kampf unterlegen, rettet uns keine Spezialfähigkeit in Hintern.
Die dicken Killstreaks ernten nur Profis, das kann einerseits auf Neulinge durchaus abschreckend wirken,
fühlt sich aber andererseits unglaublich gut an, wenn man sich Erfolge durch eigene Leistungen erkämpft.
Modern Warfare verschenkt seine Kills nicht mehr durch irgendwelche Super-Fertigkeiten, die automatisch aufladen.
Zugleich fühlt sich Call of Duty ein wenig langsamer und weniger chaotisch an als seine Vorgänger.
Weniger chaotisch würde ich jetzt mal überhaupt nicht unterschreiben bei Multiplayer.
Weniger chaotisch würde ich überhaupt nicht unterschreiben.
Ich finde, das ist noch, noch chaotischer, äh, was die, was die, ähm...
Also es ist nicht so chaotisch durch irgendwelche Spezialfähigkeiten, wie jetzt irgendwelche komischen Operator-Specialist-Geschichten.
Aber es ist halt einfach chaotisch dadurch, dass ich in Spawns-Gruppen kann und sowas.
Das ist, sagt das, was, sag nicht, das ist Max-FPS.
Ein Feuer zwar im Kompass, aber nicht standardmäßig auf der Minimap sichtbar.
Wir können also nicht die Position, sondern lediglich die Richtung von Gegnern orten.
Vorsichtiges Vorantasten ist deshalb oft auf Volksversprechende als plumpes Vorausstürmen.
Neu ist außerdem, dass man Waffen an Hindernissen auflegen und damit den Rückstoß kompensieren kann,
also wie in der Singleplayer-Kampagne. Das fördert vor allem defensive Waffenklassen,
wie die MG's, die beispielsweise in WW2 kaum echten Nutzen brachten.
Sogar Stealth ist quasi ne Option geworden.
Statt Türen einzurennen, öffnen wir sie heimlich nur in Spaltweib und erledigen nichts an den Gegner dahinter.
Aktuell sorgt das alles allerdings auch für viel Gekämpfe. Na ja.
Und dann bringen Field-Upgrades, wie die Munitionskiste oder die ferngesteuerte Drohne zum Orten von Feinden,
zudem nen kleinen bisschen Teamplay ins Spiel und liefern einen kleinen Gegenpol zum schnellen Run-and-Done-Gameplay, das trotz allem immer noch...
Alter, die Gaming-Redakteure, das sind immer solche Bots, was Multiplayer-Spiele angeht. Das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
...den Kern des Spiels ausmacht.
Auch bei den Multiplayer-Karten verlassen die Entwickler eingelaufene Pfade und werfen das altbekannte 3-Lane-Design mit 3 klaren Laufwegen über Bord.
Stattdessen sind die Maps asymmetrisch aufgebaut und vollgestopft mit atmosphärischen Details,
weiß, unzähligen Winkeln und Sichtlinien.
Damit stellt Modern Warfare bewusst den kompetitiven Charakter der Karten in den Hintergrund und setzt stattdessen voll auf Atmosphäre.
Auf Stadtkarten kämpfen wir uns durch halteingestürzte Häuserruinen, die zum Teil provisorisch mit Holzstegen verbunden sind,
über verlassene Kinderspielplätze und offene Straßen.
Dabei finden die Kämpfe meist auf verschiedenen Höhenebenen statt, die durch Leitern oder Treppen miteinander verbunden sind.
Dieses verschachtelte Design eröffnet unglaublich viele Sichtlinien und Laufwege für Flankenmanöver und bietet Distanzen für alle Waffenklassen,
ob Sniper oder SMG-Schütze.
Ja, bloß dass du absolut keinen Weg mehr sicher sein kannst, wenn du da an den Fuß vor die Tür setzt, dass da nicht gerade dich irgendeiner abaimt.
...einigener seinen Bereich und seine Berechtigung.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die Maps aber dadurch auch ungleich schwieriger zu erlernen als noch in den Vorgängern.
Bis wir uns in dem eigenen Gassengewürde einer östlichen Stadtkarte Ramasa auskanten, gingen viele frustrierende Runden ins Land,
in denen wir aus unerwarteten Richtungen erschossen wurden.
Diese steile Lernkurve hat aber zwei Seiten.
Haben wir mal den Dreh raus, eröffnen sich endlose Möglichkeiten dem Feind in die Flanke zu fallen,
oder einfach hinter der Ecke sitzen zu bleiben, was die meisten Leute machen.
...Missionsziel vom Hausdach gegenüber zu verteidigen.
Auch hier werden Neueinsteiger zunächst überfordert sein.
Auf lange Sicht entfalten sich aber mehr taktische Möglichkeiten und eine greifbare Schlachtenatmosphäre...
In Wirklichkeit ist es eigentlich eher so, dass hier hinter der Ecke einer mit der Olympia-Shotgun stehen würde und ihn jetzt direkt awnen.
Also so spielt sich das aktuell.
Ah, läuft's um die Ecke, bam, Olympia-Shotgun in die Fresse.
...der vergangenen Jahre.
Trotzdem, die Maps brauchen noch etwas Überarbeitung, doch dazu gleich mehr.
Reden wir vorher über den groß angepriesenen Ground War Modus, der in der Realität ziemlich viele Probleme hat.
Der Modus für 64 Spieler mit steuerbaren Fahrzeugen und Hubschraubern klingt auf dem Papier wie ein Battlefield-Killer,
artet aber allzu oft in Planlosigkeit und pures Chaos aus.
Wo die verwinkelten Maps sonst für Anspruch und Dynamik sorgen...
Wofür ist dieser Raum überhaupt vorhanden?
Wofür ist dieser Raum vorhanden?
Wofür ist dieser Raum vorhanden? Warum gibt es den überhaupt?
...verwinkelten Maps sonst für Anspruch und Dynamik sorgen, kommt es in Ground War ständig zu hektischen Massenschlachten,
ohne erkennbare Frontlinien, die gefühlt häufiger vom Zufall als durch strategisches Vorgehen bestimmt werden.
Mit Schuld daran ist auch die unbrauchbare Feinderkennung per Kompass,
der bei derartigen Spielerzahlen einfach nur noch durchgehend rot leuchtet,
während permanent Killstreaks wie Luftschläge oder Raketen aus Hubschraubern auf uns einprasseln.
Hier wird schnell klar, dass 64 Spieler und große Maps das Kernspielprinzip von Call of Duty an seine Grenzen bringen
und viele eigentlich durchdachte Systeme versagen.
Deutlich besser meistert Modern Warfare da die Verkleinerung.
Die neuen 2v2 Gunfight-Matches auf den kleinen Arena-Karten
bieten eine spannende Abwechslung zu den großen Spielmodi
und eignen sich für eine kurze Partie zwischendurch mit Freunden.
Stimmt schon, aber wobei das hier auch bei den Maps wieder so langweilige Maps überhaupt sind.
... ebenso gut wie als handfester Wettkampf mit E-Sport-Charakter.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare ist also ein sehr guter Multiplayer-Shooter,
hat aber auch deutlich erkennbare Schwächen.
So ist uns im Test trotz aller Verbesserungen seit der Beta
noch immer das Spawn-System negativ aufgefallen.
Auf der eher kompakten Piccadilly-Map wurde unser Team zum Beispiel immer wieder
zum eigenen Spawnpunkt zurückgedrängt, nur um dort immer und immer und immer wieder
kurz nach dem Wiedereintritt ins Spiel von kämpfenden Feinden abgeschossen zu werden.
Warum?
Hier fehlt ein Spawnflip.
Diese Map kannst du theoretisch schon gleich Rage quitten, wenn du sie im Ladebildschirm siehst.
Generell scheinen manche der Maps nicht besonders gut auf alle Spielmodi angepasst zu sein.
Vor allem Hauptquartier. Ohne Scheiß, Leute. Auf dieser Map.
Hauptquartier. Du, das ist ein Walking Simulator.
Du rennst eine halbe Stunde zum Hauptquartier.
Team Deathmatches sind einige Maps einfach zu groß
und insgesamt fehlt die Map-Exzellenz vieler älterer Call of Duty-Karten.
Und dann gibt's auch noch hier und da Probleme mit dem Netcode.
Das richtige Pepega-Map.
Es verlief der allergrößte Teil der Feuergefechte nach unseren Beobachtungen fair ab,
denn noch gab es Situationen, in denen wir scheinbar um Ecken herum oder mit einem Treffer getötet wurden.
Oder Feinde warfen uns wiederum vor, dass wir cheaten würden, was wir natürlich nicht machen.
Bulletstacking bleibt derzeit also noch ein Problem, dass künftige Patches in den Griff bekommen müssen.
Die dritte große Säule neben Singleplayer und Multiplayer von Call of Duty
ist dieses Jahr kein Zombie-Modus, sondern Spec Ops.
Infinity Ward will dabei an die Koop-Missionen der alten Modern Warfare-Teile anknüpfen
und schickt uns mit bis zu drei Freunden oder Fremden, denn es gibt doch Matchmaking,
in PvE-Gefechte auf unterschiedlichen Karten.
Hauptgas hab ich noch nicht gespielt.
Die Map-Größen reichen dabei je nach Einsatz von kleinen Kampfaränen
bis zu gigantisch großen Schlachtfeldern mit mehreren Siedlungen samt Stadion und Flugplatz.
Dabei soll die Hintergrundgeschichte von Spec Ops die Handlung der Solo-Kampagne fortführen,
de facto merkt man davon in den Koop-Matches relativ wenig.
Die eigentlich interessanten Schauplätze des Spec Ops-Modus bleiben fast durchgehend blass
und wirken häufig wie Kulissen, die von seelenlosen KI-Feinden bevölkert werden.
Nirgends gibt's Zivilisten, lebhaftes Treiben auf den Straßen oder unerwartete Ereignisse.
Das ist auch so was, was irgendwie so ein bisschen gewollt und nicht gekonnt wirkt.
...dichte Atmosphäre der Singleplayer-Kampagne.
Stattdessen ballern wir oft Horden von austauschbaren Feinden mit Dover-KI,
die viel mehr durch Masse und durch das gelegentliche Auftauchen schwer gepanzterter Juggernauts
als durch ihr kläberes Vorgehen zum Problem werden.
Zudem spawnen Feinde auch hin und wieder in unserem Rücken und bereits gesäuberten Räumen,
was unserem sorgfältig ausgetüffelten Plan oft einen Strich durch die Rechnung macht.
Denn die Spec Ops-Level sind alles andere als leicht.
Nur wer sich mit Teamkollegen abspricht, seine Ausrüstung aufeinander abstimmt
und Killstreaks zur richtigen Zeit einsetzt, erlebt das Ende eines Einsatzes.
Insgesamt hätte Spec Ops enorm von etwas mehr Liebe zum Detail,
einer besseren Inszenierung und ein paar atmosphärischen Story-Ereignissen profitiert,
also von alledem, was die Singleplayer-Kampagne so gut macht.
Stattdessen wirken die Aufgaben allesamt wie schon mal da gewesen
und die Dover-KI offenbart in den großen Arealen, dass sie nur mit Masse zum Problem wird.
Machen wir den Sack also zu.
Auch wenn es natürlich was zu kritisieren gibt, hatten wir wirklich viel Spaß mit dem neuen Modern Warfare.
Die Kampagne ist brachial inszeniert, spielt sich intensiv,
schöpft ihr Potenzial zwar nicht aus, bietet aber einen enorm unterhaltsamen Spec Ops-Porno.
Der Multiplayer führt die Serie zurück zu ihren großen Stärken
und dank Crossplay könnt ihr mit euren Freunden so flexibel wie nie zuvor zusammenspielen.
Jetzt bleibt allerdings zu hoffen, dass Infinity Ward spannendere Maps nachreicht
und all den Versprechen von kostenlosen Content gerecht wird.
Eine perfekte Grundlage dafür bietet das neue Call of Duty allemal.
Gutes Video, finde ich gut.
Die Gamestorm-Videos sind mittlerweile wirklich nice.
Aber ich meine, jetzt werden wir uns überlegen, der Spec Ops-Modus ist nicht so sonderlich toll.
Die Kampagne ist jetzt auch nur, sag mal mal so, Durchschnitt, was ich da bis jetzt gespielt habe.
Crown War ist kacke.
Maps sind viel zu groß.
Also man sieht schon, es bleibt von dem Gesamtpaket eigentlich nur ein ziemlich kleiner Teil übrig,
wo man sagt, ok, der kommt überhaupt in Frage zu spielen.
Und da hast du dann die ganzen Probleme, die du als Multiplayer hast.
Also so ein gutes Gesamtpaket, finde ich, ist das Game einfach nicht geworden.
Martin, vier Monate.
Aja ja, Pock.
Hab ich was übersehen an Subs?
Ich glaube, ich hab den Extrem-Nerd übersehen.
Hab ich dich übersehen oder hab ich dich vorgelesen?
Das ist schon eine Stunde her.
Sind wir wach oder wachen wir auf?
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist die Frage.
Ich hab dich nicht übersehen, aber das ist sauber.
Ja, nochmal Glück gehabt.
Jeder schreit mir zu sehr rum.
Komm, wir gucken uns noch eine Modern Warfare 2 Nuke an.
Komm, wir gucken uns noch eine MW2 Nuke an.
Jetzt nach dem ganzen Modern Warfare Zeug gucken wir uns noch eine MW2 Nuke an.
Auto Shotgun auf Terminal ohne Chopper.
Auf.
Gucken wir uns mal eine gescheite Map an.
Jawoll, wegsprayen.
Doch, Rust soll auch kommen.
Oh mein Gott, weißt du was, Leute, seit meinem letzten Video habe ich die AA-12 in Modern Warfare 3 benutzt, bringen wir sie wieder in Modern Warfare 2. Heute werden wir die AA-12 in Modern Warfare 2 benutzen. Im heutigen Video habe ich die AA-12 in Modern Warfare 3 benutzt, um eine MW2 Nuke zu bekommen.
Jetzt werden wir ein paar Nukes mit der AA-12.
MW2 Nuke.
Das ist im Endeffekt viel besser in diesem Spiel als es in Modern Warfare 3 ist. Whoa, Team 8, ich liebe dich so viel.
Ja, als ich euch gesagt habe, Leute, wenn euch die Videos von ihm gefallen, abonniert ihn. Ich finde die Videos sind wirklich nice. Einfach nicht viel rumgelaber, einfach Gameplay um gut ist.
Run up, play your boy.
Mom, we're just killin' them right now. Kill them Harriers in. Drop a Claymore. First game on right now. Dude, the AA-12 is so great in this game. In Modern Warfare 3 it's not bad, it's not terrible, but you can tell the difference. It's like night and day when you go from Modern Warfare 2 to Modern Warfare 3.
From Modern Warfare 3 to Modern Warfare 2.
I'm not using Chopper Gunner or AC-130, we're using Pavlo and two of their guys already left the team. So there's only four of them left. I guess they got kinda pissed off because they were getting destroyed so badly.
Primo noch an zwei Monate, dankeschön.
I don't know what to do currently. Oh, there's five of them. Oh, Claymore got a kill. No idea where they are. I'm gonna call my Pavlo in in just a second here.
No, Claymore, why'd you get a hitmarker? That sucks, badly. Let's see what KD we can finish this game with. Let's hope I get no more deaths. And I blew it. Alright, I don't really have much more time in this game so we'll go for one more streak and if I choke, we're out.
Last stand. Looks like this game's just about done. What I might end up doing is free for all so I don't really have to rely on my teammates getting a certain amount of kills so I can't get a nuke and this guy's just sitting in a corner.
Der spielt ansonsten wahrscheinlich Modern Warfare, der Typ. Der freut sich.
Even though this is like, this is a class that would be like nukes with terrible classes like marathon danger close on a freaking UMP.
I love this thing dude it's way too overpowered in this game. I think in Modern Warfare 3 it's got the respectable like the respectable kill range and damage for an automatic shotgun but in this game it's crazy OP.
Well, just like every other gun in this game though.
Es ist fast alles in Modern Warfare.
6 und 0, not bad.
Is that guy just spraying through the wall at this point to try and kill me?
Yeah. Looks like it. Someone's got Harriers.
Dude, they're just shooting stuff into this building camping in their spawn.
Like why are you doing that? Oh great, now I'm dead.
Jetzt ist er, ja.
Ja, wenn der Gegner jetzt auf mich zukommt, das...
Was ist mit dem Gegner los, Alter?
Harriers, for me, guess where I'm putting it. Right on that damn building.
Now it doesn't kill anyone.
I'm a bit confused. Here's someone shooting a silencer.
Ja, 200 IQ.
Nope, I guess I'm gonna play the whole game in here. Why not, right?
13 and 0 again. I mean though, is there really a point of me running out of this building? Probably not.
But, you know, I'd love to go back there and get at least 100 more kills.
Konnte man die sich nicht auch akimbo nehmen? Ich glaube, die gehen nicht akimbo. Oder gehen die akimbo?
Ich glaube nicht.
I'm gonna do something probably really dumb right now.
Just because I feel like it though.
Wow, I'm alive.
Don't know how.
So many explosions just went off.
22 and 0.
24 and 0.
Pavelow's down.
And I just died 24 and 0.
Yes, alright.
You have got to be kidding me.
My luck is literally just brutal. Terrible.
What the fuck ever.
It is really to the point where I just honestly cannot believe it anymore.
Oh, here's someone else walking.
This is bad news.
The other guy's right here.
G18 akimbo, ja.
Spray him, Perry, baby. He's running. He thinks he got around me too. That's funny.
Das ist natürlich eine der besten Mad for kill streaks, wenn die Gegner sich nicht abschießen.
Shit, I hear him. He's coming up right over here.
Sorry buddy.
Almost dead there.
Wobei ich ja ganz ehrlich, der russische Ansager in MW2 ist der beste.
Enemy AC 130 above.
Killed the level 1.
That's nice.
No, not bad. Hitmarkers.
Don't want someone to spawn there.
Got a Pavelow, that's nice.
I'm going to give this a second.
See when my Harrier goes down. Someone's deep over here.
Die schießen den Harrier aber auch nicht ab.
Enemy UAV spotted. That sniper was looking at me again.
Dude, this Harrier is going crazy.
I'm going for this guy too down here.
He shot the crap out of my Harrier too.
15 and 0.
Oh, someone left. People always leave when the kill streaks get crazy.
The nuke drops too.
So let's get this nuke baby.
Did he hear me throw that or something? That was weird, because I have ninja on.
He's coming back for more.
Getting close, some five off. Too bad there's only three other people in this lobby.
When the Pavelow's in the air shooting and stuff, it's just so loud you can't really hear.
Jetzt fällt er gleich runter.
He also hasn't shot a single bullet in like 20 seconds now.
I hear someone.
Why did I accidentally knife?
Not that it would have mattered.
It's because there's three people in this game and I have to kill every single one of them.
I don't know why they can't connect a full lobby here.
That kind of just screwed me.
Hey buddy, what's up?
This game is awfully quiet.
Greetings.
I guess it's time for me to calm down now for a second.
Well met.
This thing actually has crazy range.
I didn't think it shot that far to be completely honest.
I'm really going to die now.
Bye bye.
Well it's time to call these in somewhere.
Look at him, he's just standing there that guy.
Thanks bro, you're really appreciated.
How kind of you.
It was bad.
Avela without a picture on the toilet.
Here guys, to the right.
The picture on the toilet was partially removed from the map.
Yeah Flo690, I noticed that.
South Korea didn't win the World Cup.
The actual final was USA against South Korea.
But that was already in the quarter or semi-final.
It really surprised me that South Korea didn't win.
Good question.
Probably.
Oh no.
What's up with my luck? Absolutely sucking balls lately.
I actually did something good.
I joined team deathmatches, it's actually ground war domination lobby.
Only problem is we're destroyed by kill streaks at the moment.
Alright, making progress.
Go, go, go, go.
Hardcore spray and pray.
I'm gonna call these Harriers in real quick while I have the chance.
And before I die.
No, why'd I call that in? I shouldn't have done that.
Alright, let's do this baby, come on.
Hopefully my Pavelo can get some kills, my Harrier too.
Damn, they're actually going off.
Someone broke out a stinger.
My kill streaks are going off right now.
Easy, easy nuke, easy life.
Come, give double nuke.
Double nuke.
There we go.
It's crazy how good the AA12 is.
One.
It's crazy how my entire team is just sitting here getting spawn trapped the whole game.
But I still managed to get a nuke.
Der ist doch gut.
Wenn er ein Team kills machen würde, würde er selbst keine kills machen.
MW2 Schupper easy.
Too easy, ey.
Which is every day, every other day.
Yeah, hopefully you guys are enjoying.
And as always guys, peace out and have a great day.
Ach, die Videos von dem sind echt cool.
Man sieht halt einfach, dass das Gameplay schon ganz anders sich anfühlt.
In MW2.
Die Benamung ist übrigens auch fail.
Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass du jetzt Modern Warfare hast und Modern Warfare 2 allerdings 10 Jahre her ist.
Ah nee, nicht ganz 10.
Also quasi MW2 und MW3 sind viel älter als MW.
Das ist halt mal Benamung pur.
Ah echt, 2009?
History of Rainbow Road gucken wir heute wieder nicht, weil das dauert zu lange.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
I paid the worst rated computer specialist to fix my gaming PC.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Welcome to another Video. Now, what happens if you use the worst rated local PC specialist to repair your broken PC?
Well, that's exactly what I did.
So the thing about sites like Facebook Marketplace and Gumtree is that not only can people...
Facebook Marketplace?
Das gibt es?
Hab ich schon nie was von gehört.
...offer their products for sale, but they...
Genau, eBay Kleinanzeigen war das letzte Preis.
...offer their services as well.
If you're a gardener, you can offer landscaping services.
If you're a mechanic, you can offer your car repair services.
And if you fix PCs, well, you can offer your PC repair services.
Now I decided to investigate this side of things because anyone can advertise their services online.
And it got me thinking, if I use the worst rated local PC repair specialist to fix my system, what would the outcome be?
Now to do this, I took a risk with my Ryzen 5 gaming PC, but I replaced the graphics card that's currently in there, the GTX 980, with a GTX 480.
An older, fully working card that I was willing to sacrifice.
Sorry, old girl.
The concept here was simple.
I was going to put the fully working 480 in the PC, get in touch with a few PC repair specialists and see who could replace my graphics card and what their plans were for it.
Now of course, this was a fully working card, so I was also interested to see how many of these people would say, this doesn't need a repair, the card is fully working.
Now the first two people I got in contact with...
Das würde ich als PC reparier-Service allerdings auch nicht sagen, wenn ich Geld verdienen will.
... immediately came to this conclusion.
One was about 15 miles away and had a shock.
I took it in and within half an hour I had a call saying, it's not broken at all.
The second one was based out of someone's house, about five or six miles away from me and the same thing happened.
An hour or two later they called me and said, although the card probably shouldn't be paired with Horizon, it is fully working.
Now the third one is where things get interesting.
I found this guy advertising his services on the marketplace, but he had also set up an official page for himself.
His name was Jeff and so I tried to get in contact.
He messaged me back on his private Facebook page, which probably should have been the first red flag.
And here is the story of how all of this unfolded.
Now Jeff's page was the laboratory of the others I got in contact with and he was also a little more abrupt when it came to conversation.
Wissen wir auch warum es in Overwatch kaum neuen Content gibt, da es beschäftigt PCs zu reparieren.
I really trust my PC in Jeff's hands, but that's something I'm willing to sacrifice for the purpose of entertainment.
Here is the conversation that went down on a Friday evening.
Well, I started on Friday evening, but it wasn't until Saturday at 12.44.
He got back to me.
Hello, my PC isn't displaying a picture.
Hopefully your man, that is the best name for a PC Reparaturservice ever.
Is that something you can help me with?
He replied on Saturday.
Yeah, no problem. Sounds like a graphics issue.
What card have you got if you got one?
I put, going into this, pretending I had very little to no PC knowledge, I looked in device manager
and it says GTX 480, if that's what you mean.
His response was, yeah, not a brilliant card.
Well, probably stop working as it's old.
I couldn't decide.
Rude.
I then said, okay, is that something you can fix for me and how much, please?
His response almost immediately was, yes, can do.
Won't be the same card, but we'll replace with something that's just as good or better.
Just as good or better.
Drop it in and I'll do it by Monday.
Will be £100 for the card and £50 for the work.
So he's charging £100 for the...
Okay, für 100 Pfund kriegst du definitiv ne bessere Karte als ne 480.
...card itself and then £50 for the labour.
Now, I thought this was a little steep, to be honest.
It doesn't cost more than probably £20...
Willst du noch aufhauen, Watch? Nee.
...to replace a graphics card with something that can perform closely or even outperform a GTX 480.
It is an old card after all, but everyone's got their prices.
Everyone needs to eat, I understand that.
It's just that he was a little more expensive than the other two,
and considering he was running it out of his house, his costs were probably a little lower also.
But so be it, I decided to take him up on the offer
and drop the machine off at his house Saturday, early evening.
Now, I should also mention that at no point did Jeff get in contact with me
and say the GTX 480 is still working, you don't need...
Ja, der wollte die Technikkarte tauschen.
...he just did the work, which, again, fair enough, I guess.
Well, not really, but...
Let's take a look at the end result, shall we?
So, this is my newly repaired system.
For £150 we have a new, well, technically refurbished graphics card,
and it seems like Jeff decided the power supply should be installed the other way around.
Fair enough.
There wasn't much ground clearance, but I can't say as of yet
whether this new airflow configuration is beneficial.
Everything else is thankfully unaltered.
When I picked my PC up, I was shown it working
and told that the old GTX 480 was indeed broken,
but it had been responsibly recycled.
Expect to see that on eBay.
Now, we know for a fact the card was fine,
but I guess Jeff decided it needed swapping out anyway.
Thing is, the replacement doesn't look much newer.
I couldn't tell at first glance, but I asked what card
would be replacing the broken one when I dropped it off
and asked the same thing when I picked it up.
Both times I got the response, it's an invisible card.
It's in this case definitely thought that the power supply goes down there,
but well.
But well.
Why they attached the power supply, that's a good question,
probably because it's a noob.
Because it's a noob. No idea.
Let's see what it replaced.
That's what I wanted to play.
Also können wir uns merken, so ungefähr 35 FPS in beiden Games.
So, just what is this new GPU?
Is this a suitable 480 replacement?
Well, yeah, about that.
Now, starting with the same couple of Games for the comparative results
in Kingdom Come Deliverance didn't do as well.
Not quite anyway, let's just say that.
With the 545, we were averaging 13 frames per second
with 1% more than 1% lag of 12.
At least that indicates that there was no heavy lag or stutter,
but when you're running at 13 FPS, that doesn't really make too much of a difference.
Ich meine, eigentlich sind niedrige FPS ja auch besser,
weil du einfach viel mehr von dem Game siehst.
Du hast viel mehr Zeit, dir die einzelnen Sachen anzukommen.
At first I thought this was just a problem with the drivers.
I then thought perhaps it was just the game itself.
Maybe the 545 didn't agree with Kingdom Come,
and we'd have more luck in Dirt Rally 2.
With the same settings, 1080p medium,
while the story wasn't much better,
we were averaging 11 frames per second with 1% lows
and 0.1% lows of 8.
Der ist halt blöd, ja.
Ich meine, es ist ja allgemein bekannt,
dass du pro Auge nur 12 FPS siehst
und mit beiden Augen zusammen 24 FPS.
Deswegen müsste einfach ein Auge zu machen,
und schon wäre das Ganze flüssig.
...and 8 respectively.
Again, this indicates no stutter whatsoever.
Aber macht er nicht, hat halt keine Ahnung.
But with such a low frame rate, that's kind of irrelevant.
I'm sure you could tweak it a little bit more
to squeeze a few more frames out of the games,
such as using a lower resolution
or maybe even lower settings.
No, that's not whatsoever.
But with such a low frame rate,
that's kind of irrelevant.
I'm sure you could tweak it a little bit more
to squeeze a few more frames out of the games,
such as using a lower resolution
or maybe even lower settings.
That's kind of impossible.
But that's sort of besides the point in this instance.
Comparing them directly with equal settings
doesn't exactly provide us with an equal match
as far as frame rate is concerned.
So I don't think we really got our money's worth here
as far as a direct replacement is concerned.
But yeah, the things I do for entertainment.
Oh, my poor 480.
So with the comparative results aside
and dealing with the fact that the 545
is in no way a decent replacement for the 480,
I decided to test a couple of other games
and see how well this card could actually do,
starting with PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds.
PUBG. PUBG läuft, aber überall kacke.
Oder ist es mittlerweile besser?
Not a brilliant result.
And one that could possibly be alleviated
with a drop in resolution to 720p.
But all in all, it's not exactly
a fantastic gaming experience here.
The same can be said for Resident Evil 7,
which was giving us very similar results,
in fact to PUBG at 1080p,
once again with a mixture of low and normal.
This didn't really help because the game,
which runs quite well on some older hardware,
wasn't running very well at all here.
Now older games, such as the Elder Scrolls Oblivion,
will run fine. I had to fire this up, give it a test.
And it turns out...
To conclude, if you'd rather take your PC
into a shop to have any parts replaced
or anything repaired,
then I strongly suggest you do some serious research.
Check out the reviews, do your homework,
and it's always better, in my experience,
to take it to a brick-and-mortar store,
a business that's long been established.
You will pay more than if you were to replace
any parts yourself, but that's just the way it is.
I would strongly recommend looking up
how to replace any parts yourself.
Replacing a graphics card especially is super simple.
It's a matter of slotting the old one out,
slotting the new one in, and providing your power supply
is, well, powerful enough, you should have no issues.
I don't think I'm going to be contacting Jeff anymore.
He was quite a scary man in person.
I don't want to bring my PC back to his house.
I'll write this one off as a business expense,
but I just wanted to sort of demonstrate
what can go wrong should you just opt
for anyone to replace your PC.
There are many people out there.
Anyone can set up their own business these days,
so it's important to do your research
before taking your precious belongings,
especially your computer, to just anyone to repair it.
But there we have it. I hope you've enjoyed this video.
If you did, leave a like on it down below.
Share horror stories and comments down below.
Subscribe to the channel if you haven't done so already.
I'll see you next time. Bye!
...
Das heißt, was, wie geht's das jetzt eigentlich raus mittlerweile?
Nee.
Es ist übrigens auch toll, dass 19.09 das November-Update genannt wird, ne?
Ist jemand schon mal aufgefallen, dass 09 nicht der Monat November ist?
Das ist, das ist echt Microsoft Muffs. Quick, Quick, Microsoft Muffs ist das, ja.
09 ist November bei Microsoft. Na gut, ähm. Wann gibt's denn Release?
November, ja gut, haben sie ja noch einen Monat Zeit.
Zwei Monate Delay, ne? Wahrscheinlich noch mehr. So Leute, ein Video gucken wir noch.
Ein Video gucken wir noch und zwar, das hab ich schon eine Weile hier auch auf der Playlist drauf.
Und zwar die erste Ubuntu-Version, aber eine 5-Dollar-Windows-8-9-Spitze.
Was kosten eigentlich so olle PCs auf Ebay? Ich hab mir nämlich schon überlegt, ob ich
mich auch mal ein paar kaufen soll für Videos. Alter, PC. Sucht einfach mal.
Was? Sechs. Sechs Euro, was ist mit dem los? Biskette, DVD, CD, Intel Pentium, was ist das?
Vier. Naja, das ist zu, Pentium 4 ist zu neu. Das ist zu neu.
Warum wollen die so viel Geld? Was ist denn mit denen los?
Warum soll ich 100 Euro ausgeben für einen DOS 6.2 PC?
Was? Pentium 1000, was ist denn los? Hä? Weil er schwer ist.
Okay, suchen wir mal nach Windows 8-9-Spitze.
Isar, zweimal Isars. Da fuck. Alter, was ist mit euch? Was ist mit euch falsch?
Bist du Max FPS? Wie kommst du da drauf? Was ist mit euch falsch?
Pentium 150, was ist mit den Leuten los? What the fuck?
Was zum Teufel sind das für Preise? Da fuck. Ich meine, das ist keine Ahnung.
Versand kostet ganz ordentlich, das verstehe ich ja.
Ihr seid doch nicht mehr ganz dicht. Okay, Pentium 2 PC.
Ich habe mein altes Zeug leider nicht mehr.
Die sind alle viel zu neu. Wenn man nach Retro-PC sucht, ist das Problem.
Die sind... Ah, hier sowas. Das sind so Dinger, das ist ja 22 Euro und so.
Das lasse ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen für so ein olles Kackding.
Windows ME? Oh, nee. Schau mal auf. Weiche.
Isar, PC, Pentium. Das ist doch mal was hier.
Ali. All in Wonder Rage Pro, das war noch mit Fernsehausgang und so.
Aber ich bin schockiert über die Preise. Was ist denn mit euch los?
Für die Preise kriegst du einen halbwegs aktuellen Office-PC,
der viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel,
und endlich mal besser ist als der Oligrap.
Ja, sowas hier. Einen Euro. Einen Euro würde ich dafür ausgeben.
Doron 700 von 28 MB RAM. War das auch Medion? Nee. Irgendwas dreckiges.
S3-Grafikkarte. Das sowas würde ich sagen. Dafür würde ich dem Typ mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
keine Ahnung, ihm würde ich 20 Euro geben und gut ist. Da ist ja seine olle Kiste los, hat noch ein bisschen Geld.
Und ich hätte ein bisschen was für ein Video zum Rumbasteln, ein altes.
Aber ich gebe da noch keine 50 Euro oder so für aus, für so olle Dinger.
Guck mal, da hatte schon USB 1. Huge. Big Brain. Und ein Modem. Sogar ein Modem dabei.
Wenn du Grab willst, gib einfach Gaming-PC bei Amazon ein, das stimmt.
Preisvorschlag senden. Was macht das? Ist das quasi ein Angebot, das sofort an mich zu verkaufen oder was?
Oder was macht dieses Preisvorschlag senden?
Also wenn ich, da kann ich ihm jetzt keine Ahnung, ich sage, ich kriege 20 Euro von mir.
Kann man sagen, akzeptieren und oder nicht oder was? Ach so.
Kann man das nach Preis sortieren?
Das ist ja ein Retro-Computer. An dem Raspberry Pi 3 oder 4 ist nichts Retro.
DX400, das wird es aber als.
So viel olles Zeug. Hätte ich mal meinen ganzen alten Shit aufgehoben.
PC-Maus, Kabel, Retro. Das ist nicht Retro, das ist einfach alt.
Das ist Vintage.
Erstmal irgendwie komischen olle Computerbild-CDs oder sowas.
486er.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das an meinem Alter liegt. Mir geht voll einer daran ab, wenn ich so alte Hardware sehe.
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau warum, ehrlich gesagt. Vielleicht weil, ich glaube, es liegt daran, weil das damals halt alles so aufregend und neu war, weil man damit angefangen hat.
Boomer, ja. Aber wenigstens besser Big Prane Boomer als Low IQ Zuma.
Okay, wir wollen uns das Video angucken. Die erste Ubuntu-Version.
Die erste Ubuntu-Version. Oh, mein Vorschau-Browser ist gerade abgekackt, Leute.
Das heißt, ich sehe den Chat nicht. Jetzt kann der Chat Dinger machen, ohne dass ich sehe.
Boomer hat nichts mit den 60 Jahre alten Leuten zu tun. Mit Boomer sind Leute gemeint, die 2000 und so auch schon am Start waren und quasi die etwas ältere 2000-Millennium-Generation im Vergleich zu den jüngeren.
Die Bezeichnung ist eigentlich ziemlich doof.
Schau dir mal diese Montage an.
Hat schlechte Quali diese Montage. Ah nee, hat ganz gute Quali.
Ist sie von dir, die Montage, weil du geschrieben hast, schau mal an.
Stimmt von dir, hä?
So, Ubuntu.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie er Ubuntu ausspricht. Ob er Ubuntu richtig ausspricht oder ob er auch einer dieser Ubuntu-Typen ist.
Oh, er sagt es richtig, er sagt es richtig. Alter, yes, excellent.
Doch, jetzt hat er es richtig gesagt. Jetzt hat er es falsch gesagt. Eben hat er Ubuntu gesagt, jetzt hat er auch gesagt Ubuntu.
Er kann sich nicht so ganz entscheiden.
Ja, das machen die heute noch. 2004.
War das Warthog? Warte mal, war das Vorti Warthog oder so? Ubuntu 14.10? Ja, war hier, Vorti Warthog war das.
Sind heute alle Videos gesponsert von irgendwas? Na gut, zum Glück ist es nicht ExpressVPN.
Warum klebt man Klebeband auf die CD? Für bessere Performance. Dass es dann außen schneller dreht.
Das sieht heute noch so aus, ne?
Der Kommandozeileninstaller hat sich nicht allzu viel getan. Ihr kennt es ja bei mir aus dem Stream, wie der Kommandozeileninstaller von Ubuntu aussieht.
Was für ein großer Unterschied ist das gar nicht?
Das ist immer noch genau das gleiche, immer noch genau das gleiche.
Das könnte auch 19.10 teurer sein.
Man kann ja in 14.10, na ja, im Oktober 2004. Die Benamungen sind immer bei Ubuntu relativ einfach.
19.10 ist das Ubuntu aus 2019, Oktober. Und das kam Oktober 2004.
Die Ubuntu Versionsnummern sind, finde ich mit, das beste Schema, weil man sich das immer ganz gut merken kann.
Also es heißt Ubuntu, es heißt nicht Ubuntu-Jabantu, es heißt Ubuntu.
Wir haben uns extra mal in einem Video von Nelson Mandela höchstpersönlich angeguckt im Stream, wo er gesagt hat Ubuntu.
Aber das sind die gleichen Leute, die auch nicht Jira sagen, sondern Gyra oder sowas.
Das ist ja bunt deploded. Wenn du überall grafische Sachen installierst mit allem, was es gibt, schon.
Aber ansonsten ist Ubuntu immer noch, finde ich, also meine persönliche, ihr wisst ja, auf allen Servern, die ich für mich so betreibe, mache ich Ubuntu-Server drauf, weil es mir am besten gefällt.
Der Arbeit ist alles Red Hat. Aber ich finde die Ubuntu-Server-Variante ist immer noch für mich das am einfachsten zu benutzen.
Die beste Kombination aus aktuellen Paketen. Und so auch wie die Sachen konfiguriert werden, so wie man es am besten.
Okay, also es hat jetzt eine EXC3-Partition, was wir wollen.
Also wir werden die Partitionen beenden und diese Veränderungen zu dem Disk schreiben.
Und es sieht aus, dass ich meine Kamera verbinden muss. Lass mich das kurz machen.
Okay, also die Kamera ist verbunden. Sie wird jetzt nicht sterben. Das ist definitiv ein guter Sign.
Ja gut, jetzt wird es jetzt nicht alles angucken. Es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Es ist huge langsam, das Installen. Ihr kennt es ja bei mir aus dem Stream. Das dauert normalerweise 5 Minuten oder so. Fertig.
Oh, was ist jetzt los? Man konnte damals übrigens auch kostenlose CDs bestellen mit Ubuntu. Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch geht.
War eigentlich eine coole Sache. Der macht ja Werbung ohne Ende, der Dude.
Willkommen zu eurem neuen Ubuntu-System.
Es ist einfach überraschend. Ich meine, dass Ubuntu nicht mehr normal ist. Aber alles ist im Moment...
Wie sieht es mit der grafischen Oberfläche aus? Der Ubuntu hatte definitiv einen grafischen Standard.
Er hatte es genau um zwei dabei.
Okay, also wir werden hier auf dieser Seite ein Display-Manager anbauen.
Jetzt sollten wir eigentlich in Ubuntu...
Okay, also Auto-Adjustieren ist definitiv ein guter Sign. Wir werden sehen, ob der...
Okay. Ja, ich erinnere mich an diesen Kursor. Ich glaube, diesen Kursor wurde benutzt.
Es könnte eigentlich noch in Ubuntu heute benutzt werden. Ich erinnere mich nur an diesen kleinen Kursor.
Schaut euch das an. Das sieht super cool aus.
Ich muss dazusagen, mir hat ja die GNOME 2-Oberfläche... Du musst dir mal ein ReapOS anschauen.
Oh Gott, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das echt machen muss.
Ich muss dir sagen, mir hat die GNOME 2-Oberfläche deutlich besser gefallen als Unity.
Das ist die erste Version hier.
Du siehst, dass es hier eine schwarze Kugel ist. Jetzt muss ich den Monitor wieder anpassen.
Aber ich will den Monitor ein bisschen nach oben bewegen, damit es...
Ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, Leute, Positionierung auf dem Monitor musste ich die letzten 15 Jahre nicht mal anpassen.
Wo ist das NiceUGIF? Wenn mal ist das hier...
NiceU...
Das war noch da.
Wie, Passwort ist MJD? Das ist aber nicht das richtige Passwort.
Das einzig valide Testpasswort ist 123456. Das wissen wir alle.
Das war GNOME 2. Das ist GNOME 2.
Hier ist es auch.
Das ist kein Ubuntu-Logo.
Normalerweise, ja, das stimmt.
Ja, gut. Firefox. Wie viele Internetzeugs wird da nicht funktionieren.
Nein, Google geht immer. Google geht in jedem Browser, egal wie alt.
Es ist richtig alt.
Google geht. Google geht.
Google geht immer.
Das ist das normale GNOME-Browser-Icon.
Ich glaube nicht, das ist das richtige Firefox-Icon gewesen.
Wobei Firefox ja nicht von Anfang an Firefox hieß, sondern ursprünglich Firebird.
Ich glaube, das ist das richtige Firefox-Icon.
Guckt euch mal, diese Geschichte hier, die Windows jetzt mit Windows 10 bekommen hat, diese mehrere Desktop-Geschichte.
2004. In Ubuntu war das auch schon drin.
Die Kamera will fokussieren, danke.
Wenn man das Fenster umdreht, kann man sehen, dass es in der Mitte umdreht.
Man kann sehen, dass es in der Mitte umdreht.